All right, so who's up for a little chat and giggle? Are you guys doing like another singing one where we like sing like our names in harmony or something you mean for an opening of the show for you right now ready I'll go out well you hold a note and I'll build it and Jason top I don't even know what it just do it with your name welcome to smart list what's wrong with that that was perfect we were a little late today but I got a luncheon so that was great oh buttons you got it fed so so okay so I'm walking on the street around like Broadway in 70th and I'm not making this up this girl is 20 something I'm guessing she has a jacket that's open and she has like a like a lace tube top and her boobs completely out just
好，那谁想来聊聊天、傻笑一会儿？你们是不是在搞那种唱歌的环节，像用和声唱出我们的名字之类的？你是说现在就为节目录个开场对吧？准备好了，我来唱，你们俩哼一个音，然后我来丰富它，杰森，顶住……我甚至不知道这该怎么做，用你们的名字来一段吧。欢迎收听《聪明糊涂虫》（SmartLess）。有什么问题吗？这太完美了。我们今天稍微迟了一点，但我去吃了个午餐，所以挺好的。哦，干得漂亮，你把它喂饱了。好，所以……我在百老汇和七十街附近的街上走着，我绝对没瞎编，这个二十多岁的女孩，我猜的，她穿着一件敞开的夹克，里面是一件蕾丝抹胸，她的胸部完全露在外面，简直是……
the one just the one boob and I'm I'm like is everybody seeing this and and everybody like was looking at her and she was just walking around real confident with just one boob hanging up that was that it took my eyes a minute to believe it you know everybody I once saw a guy confidently hanging a shit on 6th Avenue at noon on a Wednesday you know it wasn't I was with you it was a fucking it was 8th Avenue and I'll tell you this how it went down I was walking with Jason and he goes look at that and then we see a dude and you see it actually coming out and I said thanks for making me look because now I'll never not be able to see that it was a high-pressured garden hose style one again and he didn't
就露了一个，只露了一个奶子。然后我在想：大家伙儿都看见了吗？所有人都在看着她，她就那么极其自信地在大街上晃悠，挂着一只露在外面的奶子。真的，我的眼睛花了一分钟才敢相信那是真的。你知道吗，有一次我还看见一个家伙在周三中午十二点的大道上自信地露着大便（注：此处原文口误/笑话，可能指生殖器）……你知道，不是我跟你在一起的时候。那是第八大道，我跟你讲讲当时是怎么回事。我当时和杰森一起走，他突然说：“看那个。”然后我们就看见一个家伙，你看着它实实在在地掏出来。我说：“谢谢你让我注意到这个，因为现在我这辈子都忘不掉这画面了。”那是一个高压花园水管喷头式的造型，而且他连
even bend his knees it's just I mean this is noon on a weekday on the sidewalk he was he didn't try to go to the to the corner or down an alley or anything so just so Jay you'll like the other day the other day oh my god the other day I'm here in Atlanta and and I still want to New York and I'm at the Publix here in Atlanta just buying a few few items at the grocery store hey stars are just like us you know and so I'm well and I'm pushing the cart and I've got here with my but I know and I'm here with my buddy Eli as you know oh yeah Eli got recognized at the gym the other day a guy says to him he's because he's wearing a smartless sweatshirt and the guy goes we love smart list and where'd you get
膝盖都没弯一下。我的意思是，这可是一个工作日的正午啊，就在人行道上。他甚至都没尝试去什么角落或者小巷里躲一躲，什么都没有。所以，杰森，你会喜欢这个的。前几天，哦天哪，前几天我在这里，在亚特兰大，然后我还是想回纽约。我在亚特兰大这里的Publix超市买点东西，嘿，大明星其实也和我们一样，你知道的。所以我推着购物车，我的好朋友伊莱也跟我在一起，正如你所知……哦对，伊莱前几天在健身房被人认出来了。有个家伙对他说——因为他穿着一件《聪明糊涂虫》的卫衣——那家伙说：“我们超爱《聪明糊涂虫》的，你从哪弄的这衣服？”
that he's like yeah I got him and he's like yeah you know my name is Eli and the guy goes are you Eli from this and he was no way yeah oh really are you kidding no I swear to God that's crazy yeah so he's friends with this guy at the gym anyway that's a different story but they swap number they're in Publix they swap numbers because he has got a whole like he goes to the gym I work out here at home on my own thing and he goes to the gym and he comes back and he's like yeah I ran into Gordo again my buddy there he was wearing the hockey I go how'd you start talking to him he said well he was wearing their shirt that said such and such hockey and he goes so then it was just on and I go yeah Canadians
他回答说：“哦，我拿到的。”那人又问：“哦，你知道我的名字叫伊莱吗？”伊莱说：“不会吧，真的吗？你在开玩笑吗？”“不，我发誓是真的，这太疯狂了。”“对啊，所以他现在跟健身房的这个家伙成了朋友。”总之，那是另一回事了。他们交换了电话号码，在Publix超市里，他们交换了电话号码，因为他有个……就像，他去健身房，我自己在家锻炼，他去了健身房然后回来，就说：“哦，我又碰见戈多（Gordo）了，我那个哥们儿，他当时穿着那件冰球衣。”我问：“你是怎么开始跟他搭话的？”他说：“哦，他穿着一件印有某某冰球字样的衣服。”然后我就说：“那这事儿就顺理成章了呗。”我觉着加拿大人
are just fantastic he's so sweet and he's so nice anyway Eli's very engaging and people love him you go everywhere you go yeah so anyway we're going along we're going along the aisle and we stop and he stops and he and he picks up some the men's wipes and it's a three pack and he goes oh it's a three pack they're not on their own I go what are you doing you know them getting the wipes and I go what and he goes yeah I go so he puts them in the cart at which point I push the cart away from me hands off yeah I can't be no associated with the wipes I did get a text from our friend JT Justin throw last night oh and I have to share what he said and I'm sure I'll be so happy I'm sharing this he
真是太棒了。他人超级甜，也超级好。总之，伊莱非常平易近人，人人都爱他。你去哪儿都这样，对吧？所以，不管怎样，我们继续往前走，沿着货架往前走。然后我们停了下来，他停下来，拿起了一些男士湿巾，那是三包装的。他说：“哦，是三包装的，没有单卖的。”我问：“你在干嘛？你买这湿巾干啥？”我问：“什么？”他说：“对啊。”我说：“好吧。”然后他把湿巾放进了购物车，就在那一刻，我把购物车推得离我远远的，举起双手表示“不关我事”。我可不能跟这种湿巾扯上任何关系。我昨晚确实收到了咱们的朋友JT（贾斯汀·塞洛克斯）发来的短信，哦，我得跟大家分享一下他说的话，我相信他听见我分享这个一定会非常高兴的。他
said we're chatting we're chatting let's get together we're gonna have dinner blah blah and he goes by the way I saw a picture of Bateman and our net yesterday are they skipping body day like every day that's son of a bitch wow you know listen when you're walking around with two percent body fat and freezing in the middle of summer as a result I don't want to hear it from him you know he's talk about somebody who's malnourished will yeah it's true why don't you take a run at him you know I'd like to don't worry I do as you know from his insane text that he when he's tries to be poetic you know he gets like real in our in our other thread that we have we're in too many threads now are we yeah we are Jason
说：“我们在聊天，我们在聊天，找个时间聚聚吧，一起吃个饭之云云。”然后他说：“顺便说一句，我昨天看到一张贝特曼和阿奈特的照片，他们俩这是每天都在逃避锻炼胸肌日吗？这两个王八蛋。”哇，你知道的，听着，当你满身只有百分之二的体脂，结果导致自己在大夏天冻得瑟瑟发抖的时候，我可不想听他逼逼。你知道的，说到骨瘦如柴的人……好吧，确实如此。你怎么不去跟他过两招呢？你知道，我很想去。别担心，我去了。正如你从他那些疯狂的短信里所了解到的，当他试图展现诗意的时候，你知道的，他会变得很真实。在咱们的另一个群聊里——我们现在的群聊实在太多了，不是吗？对，确实如此。杰森
just got pumped back Jason just got pumped back into the octortal cordal whirtle I know I just saw that Affleck is now not happy about it well no that got put out there that I guess that Ben as we know we had him on here but he's not part of it and he claimed that he was just in a whirtle thread with you and anyway remember Sam was all aghast yeah I'm not happy about it I didn't ask Matt to do that I just thought it would be a fun goof if he just put me back on there and then sure enough first thing the next morning it's not even 7 30 in the morning and I'm in Austin so that's 5 30 in the morning for me and these freaks who are on east time are already done with their an hour of crossword type wordplay
刚刚被强行拉回了那个“乌尔都语/华尔道夫”字谜群里（注：原文发音玩梗 Wordle 游戏群）。我知道，我刚看到阿弗莱克现在对此很不高兴。哦不，那个消息被放出来了，我猜本（阿弗莱克）正如我们所知，我们曾邀请他上过节目，但他并不是核心成员，他声称自己只是和你们在一个字谜群里。不管怎样，还记得萨姆当时震惊得不得了吗？是的，我很不高兴，我没有让马特那么做，我只是觉得如果他把我重新拉进去会是个好玩的恶作剧。然后果不其然，第二天一大早，甚至还不到早上七点半，而我在奥斯汀，所以对我来说那是早上五点三十分，这些在东部时间的怪咖们就已经完成了他们长达一小时的字谜游戏，
and they say Bateman you're up I'm like I haven't even evacuated myself yet which I brought up which I did bring up which you did yeah and I like to do my thing with this whirtle stuff when I was on deep in the afternoon right I do it I do it before I go to bed but these guys like to know who won and who lost before breakfast and talk and talk about it right and I were up Bradley and I were up early you already going like well that was that tough fuck totally I know the fourth guess yeah and I wake up I look at my text thing and I've got I've got 19 texts all right I'm like whoa something exciting is happening in my life no it's just a long whirtle thread yeah yeah all right listen let's let's let's
并且他们还说：“贝特曼，该你啦。”我就想：“我甚至还没排泄完呢。”我把这事儿说出来了，我确实说出来了，你确实说了，对啊。我喜欢在下午深处的时候玩这个字谜游戏，对吧？我通常在睡觉前玩。但这些家伙喜欢在吃早饭前就知道谁赢了谁输了，然后还要拿出来讨论一番，对吧？布拉德利和我当时起得很早，你已经在说：“噢，那局太难了，完全是瞎扯。”我知道，第四次猜测时……我醒来查看短信，发现我有19条未读短信。好吧，我当时想：“哇，我的人生中有什么激动人心的事情要发生了吗？”不，这只是一串漫长的字谜游戏聊天记录。好啦，听着，咱们赶紧……
let's let's get to it these these these uh oh there's two we do we have two guests all right now we have we've had two guests before these two they have worked together their entire career and somehow have managed a very happy and healthy family life as well it's very very inspiring they produce together they write together okay direct together they've created some of the most successful film and TV projects together as well as an enormous production company and in fact I don't think there is a more successful Hollywood couple behind the camera wow they have directed 10 films together grossing in excess probably of about five billion dollars what what and they better continue to get along not only
咱们赶紧切入正题吧。这些……呃……有两位……我们有两位嘉宾！好吧，现在我们有……以前我们也有过两位嘉宾，但这两位，他们整个职业生涯都在一起合作，不知怎的，他们还经营出了一个非常幸福健康的家庭生活，这真的是太鼓舞人心了。他们一起制片，一起编剧，好吧，一起导演，他们合作创作了电影和电视领域最成功的一些项目，还拥有一个庞大的制作公司。事实上，我觉得在镜头背后，再也没有比这更成功的、好莱坞的夫妻档了。哇！他们一起执导了10部电影，票房总额可能超过了大约50亿美元。什么？而且为了行业的健康发展，也为了他们被绑在一起过一辈子的事实，他们最好能继续合得来。好吧，肖恩，他们可不是那种夫妻关系的“一对儿”，他们是一对亲兄弟啊，伙计们！欢迎我们的朋友，罗素兄弟！
for the health of the industry but also for the fact they are stuck together for life well Sean they're not a couple couple they're a couple of brothers guys it's our friends the Russo brothers I was gonna leave that on and make you guess it's a family reunion with all of us are you fucking kidding me what's up good morning nice to meet you guys it's been about 20 years good to meet you too it's been 20 it's been 20 years since the pilot of Arrested Development but you've worked with Will a few times since then that's right and we've bumped into each other a bunch since then uh-huh a Bateman you have an aged a day I know it's amazing isn't it well I sleep in olive oil and I go down to Tijuana
我本想把悬念留着让你们猜呢。这简直是一场我们所有人的家庭聚会！你在逗我吗？怎么啦？早上好！很高兴见到你们。大概有20年没见了。我也很高兴见到你们。自从《发展受阻》试播集以来，已经有20年了，但从那以后，你们和威尔合作过好几次了。没错，从那以后我们偶然碰见过好几次。呃，贝特曼，你真是一天都没老啊。我知道，这太神奇了，对吧？我用橄榄油洗澡，然后每个月去几次蒂华纳进行实验性的医疗手术，注射点保罗·路德的血。保罗·路德的血？好吧，我本来不想说什么的……你看上去可没我……我知道，我知道，我懂。听着，这完全说得通。你知道的，我对吉米也有同样的看法，他看起来棒极了，他一点也没老。而我现在看起来就像我自己的父亲。你是不是……你是住在你家里的帐篷里吗？他在那个消音小隔间里的光线真够糟糕的。确实挺糟的。我在这边的亚特兰大，我在地下室里，我弄了这个便携式录音间，我随身带着它，这样我就可以完成所有的录音工作了。而且你们以前没见过肖恩，对吧？我们没有，没有。
a couple times a month for experimental medical work infuse some Paul Rudd blood Paul Rudd blood well I didn't want to say anything you don't look as good as I know I know I get it listen it makes a lot of sense you know I look at the same thing about JV he looks incredible he has not aged I look like I look like my own father now are you are you living in a tent in your in your home he's got a tough lighting there in the whisper booth it is tough I'm here in Atlanta and I'm in the basement and I've got this like portable booth that I bring with me so I can do all my records and it and you guys have not met Sean before is that right we we have not no no get a little remember during a casting of rest development
等一下，还记得在《发展受阻》的选角期间，当时有个讨论的话题是：能不能把肖恩从……行了吧。在格蕾丝（剧集场景/片场）那是真的吗？在他的档期间隙……什么？而且我还在等……我是说，我大概还是能抽出身来的。好吧，挺好。结果呢？结果怎么样？那个王八蛋到现在也从来没看过哪怕一集该死的剧！才不是呢，他看过两集。说出名字来！哪两集？发生了什么？那一集里，威尔正躺在沙发上说些搞笑的话，而你则是一副尖酸刻薄的样子站着。猜得真准！分镜设计是威尔坐着，而你站着。我想我记得你说的那集。不，那一集挺不错的，那一集确实挺好。不过我知道你们导演过《整夜难眠》（Up All Night），我和威尔、玛雅一起拍过《整夜难眠》。没错，千真万确。
and right there was a conversation point about no could we get Sean off of come on well in grace is that true in between his schedule what and and I'm still waiting I mean I could probably still get out probably good well guess what guess what that son of a bitch is still never seen one goddamn episode not to do he saw two episodes name them what happened in those one and two will was on the couch saying something funny you were being snarky standing up great guess the blocking was will was sitting and you were standing I think I remember the one you're talking about no that was a good one that was a good one but I did know you guys directed up all night and I did up all night with will and Maya that's right true
还有《托德·玛格丽特》（The Increasingly Poor Decisions of Todd Margaret），也有那个对吧？《托德·玛格丽特》，还有那个甜美可人的大卫·克罗斯，还有《荒野求生》（Running Wild），没错，还有《荒野求生》，我们在《荒野求生》里跟威尔合作过很多次。我们早期有过那些对话，当时我们正试图对《发展受阻》保持极大的敬意，所以你、我和米奇（赫威茨）、安茨（安东尼·罗素），我们所有人都决定把它拍得没有《发展受阻》那么好。这非常重要，这就是标杆。这可真能说明问题……好吧，好吧，好吧。事实是这样的，事实是，那是个好概念，我们也有一些不错的片段，但我们不断收到反馈，我们不断收到来自电视网高层的剧本反馈，他们说：“听着，伙计，你不能让这成为又一部《发展受阻》。”就好像那是个巨大的失败一样，他们一直对我们这么说。好吧……
and what about Todd Margaret there was that too right Todd Margaret that's sweet sweet Davey cross and running wild that's right and running well we did a bunch of stuff will on running wild those conversations we had early on where we were trying to be really respectful of a rest of development and so you and me and Mitch and ants we all decided to make it not as good as rest of that was really important that was the bar that'll show well well well the truth is this the truth is is it was a good concept and we had some good pieces and we can't getting the note we kept getting the note on the script from people at the network saying look man you can't just have this be another arrested
“你们可别觉得你们一来这儿，我们就能再搞出一部《发展受阻》来。”我们就想：“呃，我们对《发展受阻》感到非常骄傲，我不知道你们在生什么气。”他们不想让我们移动摄像机。我记得有很多轨道拍摄，如果你还记得的话。而且我想我拍那部剧的预算大概就只够买两个咸牛肉三明治。然后，一旦你们进入了漫威的世界，有没有人讨论过索性把威尔·阿奈特也带进去？就好像某种可怕的闪回一样，因为我们不想再来一部《发展受阻》对吧？有这样一些角色，叫做“伟大湖泊复仇者”（Great Lakes Avengers），而芝士人对那个组合非常重要……你们不是刚刚才想出这个的吧？这是你们早就想好的一半创意吗？我们有一个电脑文件，每当有人问起我们梦想中的漫威项目是什么时，我们就会拿出来——《伟大湖泊复仇者》。现在你们已经拍完漫威的电影了，跟漫威的事儿彻底告一段落了吗？还是说你们还会跟他们有点暧昧？你们现在都在忙自己的事，你们拍了《终局之战》（Endgame）。这就好比那是你们的终局之战，那确实就是终局之战，对吧？我的意思是，我觉得我们……你知道的，他们是非常好的朋友，据我所知……我们一直都在跟那些家伙交流，但对，我们现在的重心……
development like as if that was a big failure that they kept saying that to us like okay and you can't just think that you guys gonna come in here and we're just gonna have another rest development we're like well we're really proud of arrested development I don't know what you what are you guys are mad at it they didn't want us to move the cameras I remember is a lot of lines gate if you remember and I think I made that show for like two corn beef sandwiches and then was there any discuss once you got into the Marvel world any discussion to go ahead and bring will our net into that as well as sort of like some sort of a horrific flash forward is what was we don't want another rest of development right there are these characters
他们已经无法解读你了，他们只会……我记得乔，乔和……我记得当你们刚开始拍的时候——我忘了哪部是第一部，是《美国队长》吧，第一部是那部，对吧？那是……对，《美国队长：冬日士兵》。我很喜欢那部电影。我会……他会做得很巨大，乔，我还记得我给你发短信说：“他妈的恭喜啊，哥们儿，太牛了。”然后就像是……然后每次我都直接不发“恭喜”了，因为票房数字实在是越来越高，我就想：“好吧，他他妈的已经不需要听到‘恭喜’了，这是有史以来票房最高的电影。”但接着下一部赚得更多，然后《复仇者联盟》系列赚得更多。我的意思是，你们当时有没有感受到压力？就是说，我们该怎么超越，或者说如何去管理凯文（费奇）、管理那边整个基础设施的期望？有没有那种担心，觉得“天哪，我们怎么才能在保证质量的同时，还能不断拍出越来越多、商业上更成功的作品呢”？对，你必须让自己稍微隔离于那些围绕着电影的疯狂炒作。它们在体力上也极其消耗，我的意思是，看看我们……
called the Great Lakes Avengers and cheese man really important to that group didn't just come up with that is that something you got a half a pitch on and we do we have a computer that's our go to whenever whenever anybody asks what's our fantasy Marvel project the Great Lakes Avengers now you guys are done with the Marvel's with the Marvel stuff the group the whole thing or do you still flirt with them a little bit you guys are off on doing your own thing you did end game it's kind of like that's your end game that was the end game that's right right I mean I think we you know they're very good friends as far as I mean we've talked to those guys all the time but yeah we're focused they can't
我的意思是，天哪！不过听着，他们看起来状态极佳，一个在地下室里，一个在漂亮的办公室里，这就是不平分片酬的下场。那一定很复杂。等一下，我想更多地聊聊漫威的事情，以及你们是怎么走到那一步的，但我更想往回追溯，回到我们是如何进入你们的世界的——我和杰森。但在这之前，甚至在这之前……比如，你们俩从来没有给我留下过那种喜欢漫画书的极客印象，你们是吗？并不是。但你们拍了那部电影，你们的第一部电影，你们是从克利夫兰出来的。我们确实是，我们拍了一部名为《拼凑》（Pieces）的电影，并入围了1997年的圣丹斯电影节。这是一部靠信用卡贷款拍的电影，所以你知道的，在80年代末，索德伯格拍了一部名为《性、谎言和录像带》的电影，这激发了人们的一种热潮：“嘿，你可以用一万美元的信用卡贷款拍一部电影，然后从任何地方被发掘出来，成为一个大电影人。”而你必须得开始还清那笔债，你必须停止累积那些昂贵的利息，这就是《拼凑》的意义所在，对吧？
read you anymore they just kind of I remember Joe Joe and it I remember when you guys first I forget which was the first it was a Captain America was the first one right that was yeah Captain America Winter Soldier I love that one and I would I would he would do huge and Joe I remember texting you and saying fucking congrats man huge and then it just like and then every time that I just stopped saying congrats because the numbers just it kept getting even bigger I was like well fucking he doesn't need to hear congrats anymore it's the number one movie of all time but then but then the next one made even more and then the Avengers stuff made even more I mean was there did you feel like a pressure like how
花了十年才把那笔债还清，真的吗？是真的，千真万确。真的花了那么久？哇。确实有一段时间是这样的。好吧，所以后来索德伯格看到了《Pieces》……没错，然后他拿起电话，一周后给我们打了个电话。再次说明，两个来自克利夫兰、跟电影行业没有任何关系的家伙。这非常奇怪，只有像史蒂芬·索德伯格这样的人才会说：“我们很喜欢这部电影。”他给我们打电话说：“听着，我很乐意帮你把你的下一部电影拍出来。”然后他和乔治·克鲁尼一起创办了一家制作公司，这是简短的版本。对，他和克鲁尼为我们制作了另一部电影，叫做《欢迎来到科林伍德》（Welcome to Collinwood），那部电影在票房上简直大获成功。山姆·洛克威尔主演，没错，山姆·洛克威尔太棒了。演员阵容绝佳，但这是一部好电影，我很喜欢那部电影。在那部电影上花了大约800万美元，然后我赚了大约三十万美元。但质量足够好，然后我们继续……我们非常幸运，对，我们太幸运了，因为我们实际上在那部电影上映并票房惨败之前就被雇用了，这才是关键。没错，去FX电视台执导一部名为《幸运》（Lucky）的试播集。所以这是在《盾牌》（The Shield）首播后的第二年，FX想要用喜剧复制他们在《盾牌》上取得的成功，也就是制作一些非常黑暗、辛辣的内容。
were we going to top or try to manage the expectations of of Kevin of the whole the whole infrastructure over there was was there that was there a worry that oh my god how can we keep making more and more and more with quality but also with with commerce yeah you put you have to isolate yourself a little bit from all of the hype around those movies you have to they're also physically draining I mean you know look at us yeah I mean Jesus Christ but listener they look beautiful ones in a basement and one's in a beautiful office it's what happens we don't split the money yeah that must be complicated hang on a second I want to get more into the into the Marvel stuff and how you guys got there but I kind
凯文·莱利（Kevin Reilly），没错，凯文·莱利，对，对。所以我们制作了一种非常诡异、暗黑的喜剧叫《幸运》，它作为一部剧集并没有真正成功，但它的试播集在业内大受欢迎。每个人都看了那个试播集，它在各处都传开了。凭借那个试播集，我们获得的开会机会比我们做过的任何事情都要多。这最终让我们得以进入“幻想制作公司”（Imagine），去跟大卫·内文斯（David Nevins）谈《发展受阻》的项目。所以，内文斯是你在《发展受阻》项目中遇到的第一个人？没错，我是《发展受阻》世界的一部分。然后他说：“嘿，你们俩为什么不跟米奇·赫威茨一起吃个午餐呢？”完全正确。我想我们坐下来……我们跟内文斯坐在一起，他说：“听着，我们有这个节目，它有点疯狂，但需要花大力气去推，因为里面大约有35个不同的外景地，我们必须在一个压缩的时间框架内拍摄。你知道的，我们正试图压低预算，因为我们担心单镜头喜剧可能不会长久，因为这类节目的预算变得太高了，我们必须去竞争一下。”而且当时的宣传说它是一部相当纯粹的伪纪录片，对吧？里面甚至还有类似于……它被宣传得更像是一部伪纪录片。我的意思是，对，就像……在当时，根据我的记忆，它根本不是一部伪纪录片。对，没错，它只是一部标准的家庭正剧，我们最终……
of want to go even further back to how how we came into your world Jason and I did but even before that but even before that like what about like were you you guys never struck me as like comic book like guys were you no but you guys made that film your first film out of you guys came out of Cleveland we did we made a movie called pieces that went to the slam dance film festival in 97 and this was like this was a credit card movie so you know late 80s Soderbergh made a film called sex lives and videotape that ignited this you know hey you can make a movie for 10 grand on credit cards and get discovered out of anywhere and become a major filmmaker and you've got to start you've got to pay that
这是它的构图……这是一种相当复杂的构图。内文斯当时对我们说：“听着，罗农·霍华德认为电视上的半小时喜剧陷入了困境，他认为那种情景喜剧、舞台情景喜剧正在变得陈旧。他认为半小时单喜剧已经变得负担不起了，因为半小时喜剧获得的广告收入只有一小时正剧的一半，但制作半小时单镜头胶片娱乐节目的成本，并不比制作一小时节目的成本少一半。所以他们一直在想：‘我们得把这个搞清楚。’因此，我们想做的是——我们正在接触像你们这样的独立电影人”——因为他们知道我们是那种游击队风格的电影人——“而且拍片成本低，试着以低成本来应对。”我们很便宜，而且我们也知道如何低成本地拍摄。所以他们就觉得：“我们在试着为单镜头喜剧寻找一种新的模式，这种模式的制作成本要很低。”就在那时，乔和我，在看过剧本并体会到米奇剧本中固有的荒诞感之后，我们想：“如果能用最真实的方式来拍摄这个，不是很搞笑吗？”这就有点像新闻采集，对吧？手持摄影，没有镜头标记，没有灯光，只是纯粹的捕捉，完全没错。
one off you've got to stop accruing all that expensive interest that's what a recipe is about right it took it took it took 10 years to pay that off is that true it's true yeah did it really wow yeah it was a while but all right so then Soderbergh sees pieces that's right and and then he picks up the phone he gives us a call a week later I mean again two guys from Cleveland no connection to the film business whatsoever very strange movie only a guy like Steven Soderbergh we love this film and he calls us and says look I'd love to help you get your next movie made and then he started a production company with George Clooney this is the fast version of it yeah and he and Clooney produced another
现在插播一条来自我们赞助商的广告。《聪明糊涂虫》的部分赞助商是 Allbirds。现在你可能会觉得，“Allbirds”这个名字听起来……它们应该是一些别的东西，但其实它们是鞋子。某种程度上，鞋子可以用诸如……你知道的，像树枝之类的东西自制，你可以用竹子之类的东西打底来做鞋，你可以用各种东西把它们包裹起来。但是，当 Allbirds 已经在他们的 Allbirds 创新实验室里将这个工艺臻于完美时，你为什么还要自己用天然材料制作鞋子呢？哦，你得拉上拉链，你得穿上防护服，你得拉上拉链。他们研究如何最大化利用可持续材料，比如植物皮革、甘蔗和树纤维。这些材料如此天然，甚至可以说它们是超自然的。去试试 Plant Pacer、Tree Dasher 或 Superlight，亲眼见证“超级”究竟能达到多高的境界。我每天都穿我的 Allbirds，我知道这听起来像是编造的，像是有剧本写的，但绝不是。我穿着它们去剧院，这是我穿过最舒服的鞋子，我发誓。我每天都穿。我有一双蓝色系的，还有另一双……别的什么颜色，我不知道具体是什么颜色，因为我有色盲。但它们跟牛仔裤百搭，跟什么都搭。而且它们看起来比那种普通的运动鞋要好，因为……你知道的，你可以穿着它们去外面吃饭，而不只是当成运动鞋。你可以把它们穿出门，看起来非常时髦。所以他们的创新实验室是科学玩意的发源地，比如研究和测试可再生材料。正是在那里，他们研究出了如何用植物皮革制作 Plant Pacer，用木头制作 Tree Dasher，以及用甘蔗制作 Superlight。Allbirds 让鞋子超越了天然，达到了超自然的境界。今天就访问 allbirds.com 寻找你的完美鞋款，结账时输入优惠码 smart list，购买满 48 美元或以上即可获赠免费袜子。网址是 a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com，优惠码是 smart list。
movie for us called welcome to column would that absolutely crushed it at the box Sam Rockwell the Sam Rockwell that's right I'm Rockwell is incredible cast but great movie I love that movie spent about eight million on that film and I made about three hundred thousand dollars but it would the quality was good enough to then go on to well we were very lucky yeah we were so we were so lucky because we actually got hired before that movie came out and bombed that's the key yeah exactly to direct a pilot at FX called lucky so this was right the year after the shield premiered and FX wanted to do the same thing with comedy that they had done with the shield like make something very dark and risable
嘿，《聪明糊涂虫》的听众们，你们喜欢听我们聊天，我想即便你们明白我们并不聪明、有才华、英俊——也许是，也许不是——但“聪明”绝对不是我们的强项。这就是我们的赞助商派上用场的时候了——NerdWallet（书呆子钱包）。在这里，你可以并排比较顶级的金融产品，从而做出明智的财务决策。NerdWallet 拥有一整支书呆子团队，能帮助你在办理下一张信用卡、高收益储蓄账户等业务时做出明智的决定。这些可不仅仅是自称聪明的人，他们是货真价实的聪明人。他们拥有 CFP（注册理财规划师）、MBA（工商管理硕士），或者诸如此类别的头衔，拥有多年的经验。他们正利用自己的专业知识，为你提供顶级金融产品的并排比较和客观评级。你最近在汽油或杂货上花的钱变多了吗？你当然花了，这个世界太糟糕了。把这种消极转化为积极，把愁容换成笑容，去找一张能为你日常消费最多的项目提供返现奖励的信用卡吧！我在打车、优步、外出就餐上花了很多钱，老一套嘛。快来 NerdWallet.com 比较并寻找顶级的返现信用卡、储蓄账户等金融产品吧。NerdWallet，你所有财务决策的明智之选。
and Kevin Riley that's right Kevin Riley yeah yeah so we made this kind of really weird dark comedy called lucky that didn't actually work as a series but the pilot was like an industry favorite like everybody watched that pilot it made its it's made its rounds everywhere we got more meetings off of that pilot than I think anything we've done and that ended up getting us into imagine to talk to David Nevins about arrested so was never so was Nevins who was the first guy that you met on arrested that's right I'm part of the arrested world and then he says what hey why don't you guys have lunch with Mitch Hurwitz type thing exactly yeah I think we sat dance we sat with Nevins right and he said look
感谢 Topgolf 对我们的支持。这不是高尔夫，这是 Topgolf（高尔夫欢乐天地）。那么，Topgolf 到底是什么呢？简而言之，它们是一个体育娱乐综合体，提供包容性极高、每个人都能享受的高科技高尔夫游戏。球杆、球、球座、草皮、一个能捡球推车的玩意儿——应有尽有。将这一切与出色诱人的餐饮菜单、气候可控的击球区、巨大球道上的巨型靶标以及动感的音乐结合起来，Topgolf 应有尽有。所以，把这当作你的正式邀请，带上家人、几个朋友、一些同事，或者随便什么人，来这里痛快挥杆吧。每个人都能玩 Topgolf，即使根本不会挥杆的人——比如我。这是唯一一个你能去打上一轮，然后点上一份披萨，或者打出一个右曲球，然后再来一份披萨的地方。此外，你还能获得户外的所有乐趣，却同时享有室内的舒适——冬天有舒适的加热击球区，夏天有凉爽的击球区。所以对我来说，我喜欢去那里，因为这超级超级有趣。你可以带上所有的朋友，哪怕你高尔夫打得烂透了——就像我一样——你依然可以玩得很开心。那里有电视，顺便说一句，食物也非常棒。众所周知，杰森经常喋喋不休地谈论高尔夫，所以对我来说，这是把自己融入那个世界并感觉良好的一种方式，感觉自己真的很擅长打高尔夫，这真的非常非常酷。访问 topgolf.com/smartlist 预订击球区，来痛快挥杆吧！再重复一遍，网址是 topgolf.com/smartlist。
we have this show it's kind of crazy but it's going to take some hustling because there's about 35 location changes we got to shoot it in a compressed time frame you know we're trying to get budgets down because we're worried that you know single camera comedy may be short lived because the budgets are getting too high on these things and we got to compete a little bit and it was pitched to you as as a pretty pure mockumentary correct it weren't there even testimonials a la it was it got pushed more mockumentary I mean right like it was more at the time I think it was it was my memory it wasn't a mockumentary at all yeah no it was just a straight family drama that we ended up here here here's the
好的，回到节目中来。两件事：第一，你们从《幸运》剧组带过来的人里，DP（摄影指导）是吉姆，对吧？没错，吉姆·霍金森（Jim Hawkinson）。吉姆·霍金森绝对是个牛仔，我们在其他很多项目里也跟他合作过，比如《荒野求生》等等。吉姆加入了，你们三个之前就合作过，在需要快速拍摄、快速布光以及直接切入正题时，你们之间已经有了那种简写般的默契，而且……比如大量使用现有的光线。对，拍《幸运》的时候也是这样，对吧？那是一部非常激进的手持摄像机拍摄的剧，是在拉斯维加斯的街头实景拍摄的，所以我们不能自己布光。我的意思是，你知道的，预算并不高，那是 FX 的早期阶段。所以我们当时开发了这种游击战风格，而且我记得当时的 Dogme 95 运动在当时很轰动，如果你们还记得的话，他们正在拍那些 Dogme 电影。当时演员们会收到信，上面写着：“别指望有化妆车，自己化妆，这是一个不提供任何多余装饰的制作。”我们甚至可能在当年把那个作为剧信的一部分发了出去。我就是这么拿到《发展受阻》的剧本的。事实上，正是读了那张封面信，才让我确信他们绝对不可能让我参与这个酷炫的项目，因为它上面宣称……我们不想要你的化妆预算。
framing it's kind of a complex framing so also what Nevins said to us at the time he said look at Ron Howard thinks that the half hour comedy on television is in trouble he thinks the sort of the sitcom the stage sitcom is getting stale he thinks the half hour single camera comedy has become come unaffordable because you get half the ad revenues for half hour comedy that you do for an hour long drama but it doesn't cost half the price to produce a half hour of single camera filmed entertainment that it does to take an hour so they're like we're trying to figure this out so what we want to do is we want to take a we're reaching out to indie filmmakers like you because they knew we were kind of gorilla style filmmakers
除了那个之外，对，我们不想要任何传统的那种、基本上是平庸且安全的电视老套路。而那简直就是我的代名词。不，嘿，不，威尔，没关系。杰森，你怎么敢用多机位拍摄？你这么说……让我们来聊聊选角吧，我们可以谈谈这个，因为这是真的。当时业内对贝特曼确实存在一种偏见，对吧？我记得你们不断地把我叫去，让我和其他演员一起试镜，不断把我推到电视台高层面前。当时一直在进行这样的讨论，因为安东尼和我都觉得：“这家伙简直完美，为什么我们不能选他？”而他们则会说：“你知道的，他就是个……你知道的，他演过很多没能获得播出预定的试播集，他有点被诅咒了，我不知道这到底是不是……”我们听到这些时，只能一脸茫然地呆站在那里，心想：“这是我们听过最蠢的事了，你们根本不知道我是谁。”哦，不，我们看过你的作品，我们看过你……你和克鲁尼在试播集的世界里有着相当漫长的职业生涯，可以说拍了11个试播集之类的，对吧？事情对乔治来说也有过转机，乔治当时也有同样的偏见，对吧？他有很多失败的试播集之后才……对，对，对。我记得当时觉得自己极其幸运能得到那个角色。我的意思是，我不确定会有多少人看这部剧，但我知道它代表了我一直在做的事情的完全对立面，我希望能借此彻底翻盘。我的意思是，如果这部剧行不通——因为剧里每个人都太疯狂了——如果没有一个作为观众代入点的渠道，没有一个观众可以通过其进入剧情的角色，那就行不通。喜剧里最不需要做的事情就是：当你有一个正常人而其他所有人都很疯狂时，这个正常人很难逗笑观众。但你们的情况恰恰相反，我们一直挂在嘴边的话就是：“你知道的，这个角色将会很平淡。”而且当时还有其他演员在强行塞给我们，他们非常一本正经，但拍出来却有一种平庸无奇的感觉。等等，我从来没听过这些名字。你们喝得够高、敢开始爆料其中一些名字了吗？还是说我们应该等一下，去喝杯啤酒？现在是周日早上啊。如果你是刚加入我们的听众，感谢你收听《发展受阻》重温播客。听着，我有问题要问你们，我想聊聊《美国队长：冬日士兵》。等等，漫画书狂热粉，我们待会儿再聊。我们已经花了过去八集的时间在聊极客小镇、星球大作业、塔巴斯科剧院以及那些狗屁倒灶的事了。求求你，给我们一分钟，让我们有那么一个瞬间和罗素兄弟聊聊天！顺便说一句，我要说的是，杰森，所以……去吧，去吧。不，我只是想说，听着你们之前做的那些关于《发展受阻》的节目，我总是为肖恩感到极其糟糕。我来到这里时就想：“天哪，我们真的要对肖恩再做一次这种事吗？”这感觉有点像个邪教，我太喜欢了。他现在还在消化他午餐吃的炸鸡三明治呢。
and cheap to try to react cheap we're cheap but also we know how to shoot cheaply yeah so they're like we're trying to come up with a new model for a single camera that will be cheap to produce and that's when Joe and I after seeing the script and seeing the level of absurdism that is inherent in Mitch's voice we thought well wouldn't this be funny if he tried to like shoot this in in the most real way possible it's sort of like news gathering right handheld no marks no lights just just gathering it exactly and now a word from our sponsor smart list is brought to you in part by all birds now you think like the name all birds that that they would be something else but their shoes in a way
所以杰森进来了，你们俩都兴奋极了，他简直就是完美的……我一直说他是完美的空白画布，对吧？就像每种颜色……就像一张白纸，你给他台词朗读，他照着你说的任何话去做，简直就是一张白纸。为其他角色的彻底绽放提供了一张最白的画布。所以他进来了，然后他读了台词，接着你们俩就觉得：“太对了，有种平反的感觉，他太棒了。”然后你们开始围绕这些碎片进行构建，试图找到所有其他的演员。这一定……我的问题是，事情的发展如你们所想的那样吗，还是说这一切都以某种非常意外的方式发生？比如：“哦，操，这个人，还有这个人，简直太惊喜了！”我的意思是，你可能才是最大的惊喜，但如果我们经历的话……因为那是整部剧最难选角的部分，不是吗，乔？那是绝对最难的部分。而且，威尔，我们对乔的理解一开始其实是错的。谢谢你，还记得吗？有一段时间我们把乔塑造得像那种“来，拉我手指头”的怪叔叔，那种住在阁楼里的怪人。所以我们当时试镜了许多年纪大得多的演员，但感觉一直很惊悚。你知道，你本可以叫他“放屁阿奈特”（Fartnet）。然后我们的阿奈特变得更惊悚了，完全正确。但我认为迈克尔·塞拉（Michael Cera）应该是第一个被定下来的，如果我没记错的话。但正如你们所知，那部剧整个选角过程非常艰难。电视网其实从来没有真正喜欢过这部剧。不，正如我们都知道的，当它开播的时候，甚至在那个时候也是如此，甚至在赢得艾美奖之后，他们都觉得：“哦，操，我们现在不能取消它了。”不，他们给我们送了一辆冰激凌卡车……记住，不是卡车，是一个冰激凌甜筒，还有一个挂在警卫室门禁栏杆上的横幅。那是被二十世纪福斯公司的标志挡住的，所以除非你从正下方开车过去，透过天窗才能看到它。如果你刚好停在正下方的话。然后我去想：“嘿，伙计们，我们昨天刚凭最佳喜剧赢了艾美奖，这就是我们的冰激凌手推车？连电动机都没通电！”天哪，那可真是一辆手推车，这不是夸张，太搞笑了，天知道。那里面有十根冰棍，上帝保佑他们。在从来没见过你们的情况下，你知道的，导演双人组、编剧双人组、制片人双人组并不多见，更不用说像你们这么成功的了。在不认识你们的情况下，我想问一些显而易见的问题：你们俩在小时候，心里都有这个秘密，都热爱这个行业，却又瞒着对方不让对方知道吗？在哪个时刻，你们会觉得：“嘿，我也想干那个！嘿，我们应该……”
shoes could be homemade from things like you know found like you could build shoes with like you know a sticks and like the bottom of like bamboo and you could wrap them and stuff like that but why would you make your own shoes out of natural materials yourself when all birds has already perfected the process in the all birds innovation lab oh you got to zip up for that you got to suit up you got to zip up they research how to make the most out of sustainable materials like leather made from plants sugar cane and tree fibers materials so natural one might even say they're super natural try the plant pacer tree dasher or super light to see for yourself how super super can really get I wear my all birds every
鞋子可以自己用各种材料手工制作，你知道的，比如树枝、竹子的底部，然后把它包起来之类的。但是，当 Allbirds 已经在他们的 Allbirds 创新实验室将这个过程完美呈现时，你为什么还要自己用天然材料制作鞋子呢？哦，你得穿上防护服，你得拉上拉链。他们研究如何充分利用可持续材料，比如植物皮革、甘蔗和树木纤维，这些材料如此天然，甚至可以说是超天然。快来试试 Plant Pacer、Tree Dasher 或 SuperLight，亲身体验一下什么是真正的超天然。我每天都穿着
day I know that sounds like a made up thing like that scripted but it's not I wear them I walked to the theater in them they're the most comfortable shoes I've ever had I swear I wear them every day I got a blue color one and and then another color I don't know what it is because I'm colorblind but they go with jeans they go with everything and they kind of look better than just like you know regular gym shoes because they kind of you know you can go out to eat with them instead of like gym shoes you can kind of wear them and they look stylish so their innovation lab is the home for science he stuff like research and testing renewable materials that's where they figured out how to craft the plant pacers with
我的 Allbirds。我知道这听起来像是编造的，像是剧本里写出来的，但并不是。我穿着它们，我穿着它们走到剧院，这是我穿过最舒服的鞋子，我发誓。我每天都穿着它们，我有一双蓝色的，还有一双别的颜色的，我不知道是什么颜色，因为我有色盲，但它们跟牛仔裤很搭，跟什么都很搭。而且它们看起来比普通运动鞋要好，因为你可以穿着它们出去吃饭，而不是像运动鞋那样，你可以穿着它们，看起来很时尚。所以他们的创新实验室是科学的大本营，他们研究和测试可再生材料，这就是他们想出如何制作 Plant Pacer 的地方，鞋面采用
leather made from plants the tree dashes from wood and the super lights from sugar cane all birds is making shoes better than natural they're super natural find your perfect pair at all birds dot com today and use code smart list for free socks with a purchase of forty eight dollars or more that's a l l b i r d s dot com code smart list Hey smart list listeners you like to listen to us I think even though you understand we are not smart talented handsome maybe maybe not sure but smart is not one of our strong suits that's where our sponsor comes in nerd wallet where you can compare top financial products side by side and make smart financial decisions nerd wallet has a whole team of
植物皮革，Tree Dasher 采用木材，SuperLights 采用甘蔗。Allbirds 制作的鞋子超越了天然，它们是超天然的。今天就到 allbirds.com 寻找你的完美搭配，结账时输入优惠码 smart list，购买 48 美元或以上的商品即可获赠免费袜子。网址是 a-l-l-b-i-r-d-s.com，优惠码是 smart list。嘿，smart list 的听众们，你们喜欢听我们说话，我想即使你们明白我们并不聪明、才华横溢、英俊——也许吧，也许不一定——但聪明绝对不是我们的强项。这就是我们的赞助商派上用场的时候了：NerdWallet，在这里你可以并排比较顶级金融产品，做出明智的财务决策。NerdWallet 拥有一整支
nerds who help you make smart decisions on your next credit card high yield savings account and more and these aren't people who just say they're smart they're like actually smart they've got CFPs MBAs whatever those are years of experience and they're using their expertise to offer side by side comparisons and objective ratings on top financial products for you are you spending more on gas or groceries lately of course you are the world is terrible turn that negative into a positive turn that frown upside down and find a cashback card that rewards you for what you spend the most on I spend a lot of money on cabs uh uber's uh dining out you know same old same old compare and find top cashback credit cards savings
智囊团，他们帮助你在下一张信用卡、高收益储蓄账户等方面做出明智的决定。这些人可不是那种自作聪明的人，他们是真正的聪明人。他们拥有 CFP、MBA，或者诸如此类的头衔，拥有多年的经验，他们利用自己的专业知识为你提供顶级金融产品的并排比较和客观评级。你最近是不是在汽油或杂货上花了很多钱？你当然是，这个世界太糟糕了。把消极转化为积极，转悲为喜，找一张能为你消费最多的项目提供奖励的返现卡吧。我花了很多钱在出租车、优步、外出吃饭上，老一套嘛。来 NerdWallet.com 比较并寻找顶级返现信用卡、储蓄
accounts and more at nerd wallet com nerd wallet the smartest decision for all your financial decisions thank you to top golf for their support it's golf it's not golf it's top golf so what exactly is top golf in short there are sports entertainment complex that features an inclusive high tech golf game that everyone can enjoy clubs balls tees turf a ball picker uppercart thing it's all there pair that with an outstanding food and beverage menu climate controlled hitting bays giant targets in their giant fairway and loud music and top golf has it all so consider this your formal invitation to grab the fam a few friends some co-workers maybe and come play around everyone can play top golf even if no one
账户等产品。NerdWallet，你所有财务决策的最明智选择。感谢 Topgolf 对我们的支持。这是高尔夫，不，它不是高尔夫，它是 Topgolf。那么，Topgolf 到底是什么呢？简而言之，它们是一个体育娱乐综合体，拥有每个人都可以享受的包容性高科技高尔夫游戏。球杆、球、球座、草皮、捡球卡丁车一样不少。再加上出色的餐饮菜单、温度可控的击球区、巨大球道上的巨大目标以及劲爆的音乐，Topgolf 应有尽有。所以，把这当作你的正式邀请，带上家人、几个朋友、一些同事，来打上一场吧。每个人都可以玩 Topgolf，即使没有人
can swing a club hi like me it's the only place you can play around and then order another or hit a slice then grab a slice plus you'll get all the fun of outside but with the comforts of inside comfy heated bays in the winter and cool bays in the summer like so for me I loved going because it's super super fun you can bring all your friends even if you're terrible at golf like I am you can still play there's TVs there's the food is fantastic by the way so all you know Jason will constantly talking about golf so this is a way for me to infuse myself into that world and feel good about it like kind of feel like I'm really good at it it's really really cool visit top golf dot com slash smart list to book a bay
会挥杆。嗨，就像我一样。这是唯一一个你可以去打一场，然后再点一份，或者打出一个切球，然后再来一份披萨的地方。此外，你还能享受到户外的所有乐趣，同时又拥有室内的舒适——冬天有舒适的加热击球区，夏天有凉爽的击球区。所以对我来说，我喜欢去那里，因为超级超级好玩。你可以带上所有的朋友，即使你高尔夫打得很烂，就像我一样，你依然可以玩。那里有电视，顺便说一句，食物棒极了。你知道的，杰森一直在谈论高尔夫，所以这是我融入那个世界并感觉良好的一种方式，感觉自己真的很擅长。这真的很酷。访问 topgolf.com/smartlist 预订击球区
and come play around again that's top golf dot com slash smart list all right back to the show two things so one is also the guy you brought with you from lucky was your DP was Jim right that's right Jim Hawkinson and Jim Hawkinson who's just an absolute cowboy who we work with a bunch on our other stuff too and running wild and etc and Jim came in and you guys the three of you guys had worked together and already had that you already had that shorthand when it came to shooting really quickly lighting really quickly and just getting you know right using a lot of existing light yeah lucky was the same thing right it was a very aggressive handheld show shot with a shot on the streets
来打一场吧。再次强调，网址是 topgolf.com/smartlist。好的，回到节目中。两件事，一是你从《幸运》带过来的那个摄影指导是吉姆对吧？没错，吉姆·霍金森。吉姆·霍金森绝对是个牛仔，我们在其他很多项目上也经常跟他合作，比如《荒野求生》等等。吉姆加入了，你们三个人一起工作过，在拍摄速度非常快、布光非常快、直接使用大量现有光线方面，你们已经有了那种默契。对，《幸运》也是一样，对吧？那是一部非常激进的手持拍摄剧，在拉斯维加斯的
of Vegas so we couldn't light things I mean you know not a big budget it was fx early phase of fx and so we had this we had developed this running gun style and and I remember you know the dogma was big at the time they were making the dogma films if you remember that where you know actors were getting letters that said don't expect a trailer do your own makeup you know this is a no frills production we may have even sent that out with the script at one that's how I got the script to arrest development yeah in fact it was read it was reading that cover sheet that convinced me that there's no way they're gonna let me be a part of this cool thing because it was it was declaring like we don't want your makeup
街头拍摄的。所以我们不能去布光，我是说，你知道的，预算不高。那是 FX 的早期阶段，所以我们开发了这种游击式的拍摄风格。我记得当时道格玛运动很火，如果你们还记得的话，他们在制作道格玛电影，演员们会收到信，上面写着“别指望有化妆车，自己化妆吧，这是一部没有花哨装饰的制作”。我们甚至可能在剧组发剧本时就把这封信发出去了，我就是这样拿到《发展受阻》的剧本的。是的，事实上，正是阅读那份封面声明让我确信他们绝不可能让我参与这个酷炫的项目，因为它上面写着我们不需要你的化妆
budget well there's that but yeah we don't want any of the traditional sort of known basically hacky safe TV stuff and that's that was my middle name no hey yeah no will it's okay Jason how dare you multi cam you say that let me say that we get into the casting of it we could talk about that because it was true there was a stigma against Bateman at the time yeah and I remember we kept bringing you in and bringing you in with other actors to keep putting you in front of the studio and there was this conversation constantly because Anthony and I were like the guy's fucking perfect why can't we cast them and they go you know he's you know he's just bring guy he's been in a lot of pilots that haven't
预算。不仅如此，还有——是的，我们不需要任何传统的、那种为人熟知的、基本上是平庸且安全的电视套路。而那简直就是我的代名词，没有啦，威尔，没关系。杰森，你怎么敢！多机位拍摄，你这么说……让我把话说完，我们来聊聊选角吧，我们可以谈谈这个，因为这是真的。当时对贝特曼确实存在一种偏见。是的，我记得我们一次又一次地把你带去见其他演员，让你不断地在电视台高管面前亮相。当时一直在讨论这个问题，因为安东尼和我都在想：“这家伙简直完美，为什么我们不能选他？”而他们会说：“你知道的，他就是个配角演员，他演过很多没能播出的
gone to air he's cursed a little bit I don't know that this is the we would hear this and just have these blank stares on our faces like this is the stupidest thing we've ever heard that you had no idea who I was like oh no we watched you we watched you well you had just and Clooney had somewhat of a a long career let's say in the pilot world 11 pilots or something yeah and things were working out for him George had the same stigma though right where he had like a bunch of failed pilots before we are right right right now I remember feeling incredibly lucky that I got that I mean I wasn't sure how many people were gonna watch the show but I knew that it represented a complete opposite for the
试播集，他有点受诅咒，我不知道这到底是不是……”我们听到这些话，只会面面相觑，心想：“这是我们听过最蠢的事。”你根本不知道我是谁。哦不，我们看过你的作品。你和克鲁尼在试播集的世界里都有过一段相当长的职业生涯，可以说拍了11个试播集之类的，是的，事情对乔治来说很顺利。不过乔治也有同样的偏见，对吧？他在我们之前也拍了一堆失败的试播集，对吧？对。现在我回想起来，觉得自己能得到那个角色真是幸运得难以置信。我的意思是，我不确定有多少人会看这部剧，但我知道它代表了我一直在做的事情的完全对立面，希望能借此彻底重塑自己。我的意思是，如果这部剧行不通，那是因为剧中的每个人都太疯狂了，如果没有一个观众的纽带，如果没有一个观众可以借以进入剧中的角色，这部剧就无法运作。喜剧中最不需要做的事情就是，当你有一个正常人而其他所有人都很疯狂时，要让这个正常人逗笑是非常困难的。但你身上发生的情况恰恰相反，这也是我们一直强调的：你知道，这个角色将会很平淡，而且当时还有其他演员想硬塞给我们，他们非常一本正经，拍出来有一种平庸的感觉。等等，我从来没听过这些名字。你是不是喝得够多
stuff that I had been doing in the hopes of creating a reset I mean like it this show doesn't work because everyone is so insane on the show it didn't work without a conduit for the audience somebody that the audience could come in through and what you don't want to do the comedy is when you have a straight man and everyone else is insane it's very hard for the straight man to get laughs it's the opposite was true with you and that's what we kept saying is you know this character is going to be flat and there were there were other actors that were trying to push on us that were you know very straight and it was just it had a generic feel to it wait I've never heard these names are you drunk enough
可以开始爆料其中一些名字了？我们要不要等一下，去喝杯啤酒？现在是个星期天早上。如果你刚加入我们，感谢收听《发展受阻》重温播客。听着，我有个问题想问你，我想聊聊《美国队长2：冬日战士》。等等，漫画书呆子，我们会聊到那里的。我们已经花了过去八集的时间在聊书呆子城、星球大战、塔巴斯科剧院之类的破事了。快闭嘴一分钟，让我们有机会跟布鲁斯聊聊……顺便说一句，我要说的是，杰森，所以……去吧，去吧。不，我只是想说，听你以前跟《发展受阻》那些人合作过的其他节目，我总是为肖恩感到难堪。我来的时候心想：“天哪，我们真的要对肖恩再做一次这种事吗？”这有点像个邪教，我喜欢。他还在消化午饭时吃的炸鸡三明治呢。对吧？所以杰森来了，你们都很兴奋，他就是完美的——我一直这么说——完美的空白画布，对吧？就像一张白纸。你让他念台词，他完全照你说的做，就像一块纯白的画布，能让其他颜色真正脱颖而出。所以他来了，他读了剧本，然后你们就觉得：太棒了，你们得到了证明，他太棒了。然后你们开始围绕他构建其他角色，你们开始试着
to start sharing some of these names should we wait just go get a beer it's a Sunday morning right now if you're if you're just joining us you're thanks for listening to the arrest of development rewatch podcast listen I have a question for you I want to talk about Captain America the winter soldier hold on comic dork we're going to get there we have spent the last eight episodes talking about dorkville and Star Wars and Tabasco theater and shit fuck up for one minute let us have one moment to talk to the Bruce over by the way I will say Jason so go ahead and go ahead no I just want to say you're listening to your other shows that you've done with the arrest of development people I would always feel horrible
找到所有其他演员。这一定……我的问题是，事情的发展如你们所愿吗？还是说一切都以这种令人惊讶的方式发生，比如“哦，天哪，这个人太让人惊喜了”？我的意思是，你可能才是最大的惊喜，但如果我们逐个来看的话……因为那是选角最难的部分，对吧，乔？这绝对是最难的部分。而且，我们对乔曾有过错误的理解，谢谢提醒。你们还记得吗？有一段时间，我们把他演成那种“来捏我屁股”的怪叔叔，那种住在阁楼里的怪人。所以我们带了很多老演员来试镜，结果演出来越来越像个变态，你知道的……你干脆直接叫他“屁股怪”得了。后来我们的“屁股怪”变得更变态了。确切地说。但我认为，如果我没记错的话，迈克尔·塞拉应该是第一个定下来的。但正如你们所知，那部剧的整个选角过程非常艰难。电视网其实从来都不怎么喜欢这部剧。不，正如我们都知道的那样，即使它开播之后也是如此。甚至在那之前，比如即使在赢得艾美奖之后，他们也是一副“哦操，现在我们不能取消它了”的态度。不，他们给我们送了一辆冰淇淋卡车，等等，不是卡车，是一个冰淇淋蛋筒，还有一个挂在门禁大门上方的横幅。那个横幅被20世纪福斯的巨型标志挡住了，除非你从正下方开车过去，透过天窗往外看
for Sean and I like coming into this I was like oh my god are we are we really going to do this to Sean again it is kind of like a cult I love it he's still fighting digestion on his on his lunch he's fried chicken sandwich yeah did you so Jason comes in you guys are stoked he's the perfect I've always said the perfect blank canvas right like every orange like a blank give a line readings he does whatever you tell me just the white canvas just the whitest canvas for the for the other colors to really pop so but he comes in and then and then he comes in and he reads and then you guys are like yeah you feel vindicated he's he's great and then you start building the pieces around and you start trying to
否则根本看不见。如果你刚好就在它正下方……然后我去想：“嘿，伙计们，我们昨天刚因为最佳喜剧赢了艾美奖，这里有个连铃铛都没电的冰淇淋车！”天哪，真是的。没错，你得自己去拿冰淇淋。这绝不是夸张，太搞笑了，天知道。里面有10根冰棒。上帝保佑他们，在从未见过你们的情况下，你知道的，导演搭档、编剧搭档、制片搭档并不多，更不用说像你们这么成功的了。在不认识你们的情况下，我想问一些显而易见的问题，比如：你们俩小时候，有没有这种秘密，都超级热爱这个行业，却又瞒着对方？你们在什么时候心想：“嘿，我也想做那个；嘿，我们应该……”
find all those other actors and it just it must have been like a my question is did it go the way you thought it would or did it all happen like in this kind of surprising way like oh fuck this person and this person is super surprising I mean you are probably the biggest surprise but if we go through yeah because that was a hard hardest part to cast wasn't it Joe it was by far the hardest part and well we had it we had an incorrect take on Joe by thank you remember that amp for a while we were playing him like the pull my finger uncle this weirdo that was you know living up in the attic and so he we're bringing in a lot older actors and it just kept going creepy you know yeah you could have just called
我们出去为工作室筹集资金，进行融资，有点像本和马特正在做的那样。对，完全是这样。对我们来说，我的意思是，我认为这是一个行业中非常颠覆的时期，能有一个让你受到保护的地方，对吧？你可以保护自己，你可以做你想做的工作，以你想要的节奏，雇用你自己，基本上就是这样。所以，这才是我们的重点：让自己成为自己作品的粉丝，成为自己雇主的粉丝。你在后面嘟囔什么呢，乔？在电影院里做自己的粉丝，只要做自己的粉丝就行了。嘿，你们俩花多少时间……
him fart net then we got our net got even creepier exactly but I think it was I think Michael Sarah was first if I remember correctly but it was as you guys know the the whole casting process on that show was difficult the network never really loved the show no even you know as we all know when it hit the air but even back then it was like even after winning an Emmy they were like oh fuck we can't cancel it now no they sent us an ice cream truck remember not truck an ice cream cone and a banner over the guard gate 20 that was blocked by the main 20th sign so you couldn't see unless when you drove you could see it through your sunroof yeah if you were right underneath it and then I go and think like
我知道你们一直在说“孵化”。当你们刚出道时，你们是年轻的电影制作人，得到了史蒂芬·索德伯格的认可，或者说可以说是被他发掘的。那么，你们花多少时间去寻找那些年轻的新锐人才和年轻的声音呢？因为有很多人都在试图拍电影，或者正在拍电影并将它们发布到网上等等，就像索德伯格对你们做的那样。是的，你们会花很多时间做这种事，寻找新锐人才吗？当然会。我的意思是，这是我们 Agbo 公司议程中的重要部分。因为我们能够……这家公司建立的方式是一个资金充足的公司，它制作大型项目。我们有足够的产能和空间，而且乔和我也有同感，觉得我们对宇宙有一种亏欠的 karmic debt（因果债），要去寻找那些有趣的、有重要故事要讲述的艺术家，并想方设法将这些电影拍出来，因为其中有些故事如果没有这种体制是绝无可能拍出来的，对吧？你知道的，就像我们自己的故事如果没有这种体制也绝无可能拍出来一样。所以这对外我们来说非常重要。事实上，看看《瞬息全宇宙》吧，恭喜，谢谢。我想聊聊那个，对你们所有人来说都是个多么棒的夜晚啊。那真是难以置信，巨大无比，他们是……我的意思是，他们
hey guys we won the Emmy yesterday for best comedy here's an ice cream cart yeah with the bell not even powered so man it was a man that's right you had to get your own ice cream out by the way your own ankle is not an exaggeration it's so funny God knows and there were 10 bars in it God bless him having never met you guys you know there's not a lot of directing duos writing duos producing duos let alone as successful as you guys are I'm not knowing you guys I want to ask the obvious questions like how did you guys did you both when you were kids have this have this secret about loving the business and you didn't let each other know like at what point where you're like hey I want to do that too hey we should
是一群……
do it together two kids from Cleveland that's right yeah a couple of indians fans yeah we grew up on the east side of Cleveland and um anthra was getting a law degree uh and uh it was this 94 and I was and I was getting an MFA in acting or both at the same school case western in Cleveland we both came back for uh to our hometown to go to school and he was really frustrated with law school and uh I felt like I didn't ultimately want to be an actor and we started thinking about directing we did some black box stuff and started working on some comedy sketch stuff together and then we decided to write a movie and Robert Rodriguez had written a book uh about making El Mariachi for seven thousand dollars and again this contributed
一起努力，两个来自克利夫兰的孩子，没错，对，两个印第安人队的球迷，对，我们在克利夫兰东区长大，然后，安东尼当时在读法学学位，那是94年，而我当时在读表演艺术硕士，我们都在克利夫兰凯斯西储大学上学，我们俩都回到了家乡上学，他对法学专业感到非常沮丧，而我感觉自己最终不想当演员，我们开始考虑导演工作，我们做了一些黑匣子剧场的排练，开始一起做一些喜剧小品，然后我们决定写一部电影，罗伯特·罗德里格斯写过一本书，讲的是如何用七千美元拍摄《杀手悲歌》，这再次推波助澜
to that craze that was going on at the time and so we decided to make a film and we wrote a script called pieces it was very dark comedy right are you telling your family this are you telling your mom and dad like are you like hey we're writing a movie they're like yeah good for you guys like what's going on answer tell that story that's okay but you but you never I would love that but you never did it as kids it wasn't it wasn't until you were older in college no no we weren't Spielberg in the backyard with a camera right we were just we were more cinephiles we were just guys who went to watch a lot of movies we had a lot of going to movies a lot of friends that would go we'd all quote films I mean
迎合了当时的那股狂热，所以我们决定拍一部电影，我们写了一个剧本叫《碎片》，是一部非常黑暗的喜剧，等等，你们把这事告诉家人了吗？你们告诉爸妈了吗？比如，你们说“嘿，我们在写电影”然后他们说“哦，很好，祝你们好运”之类的情况是怎么样的？安东尼，讲讲那个故事吧，没关系，但你们从来——我倒希望如此，但你们小时候从来没拍过，直到你们长大上大学才开始，不，不，我们可不是在后院拿着摄像机当斯皮尔伯格，对，我们只是更喜欢电影，我们就是那种经常去看很多电影的人，我们经常去看电影，有很多朋友一起去，大家都会引用电影里的台词，我的意思是
just sort of the traditional high school experience of you know yeah um you know watching movies talking about um yeah doing lines all day long making each other laugh oh wait it's how did that go down oh so eventually as we started to like get more and more serious about it I eventually did tell my parents that I was living in their house at the time that I was going to leave film school to like put go all in on the filmmaking efforts and I think yeah my dad didn't speak to me for like six months even though I was living in the same house with them no way he would kind of grunt as we would pass each other at the refrigerator or something but um but anyway eventually he became a very big supporter
这有点像传统的高中生活经历，你知道的，看电影，讨论电影，一整天都在对台词，把彼此逗笑，哦等等，后来是怎么发展的？哦，所以最终当我们开始对这件事越来越认真时，我最终确实告诉了我父母，我当时住在他们家，我要离开电影学校，全身心投入到电影制作中，我想，是的，我爸有大约六个月没跟我说话，尽管我和他们住在同一个屋檐下，绝不可能，当我们擦身而过经过冰箱之类的东西时，他只会发出哼哼的声音，不过，不管怎样，他最终成了我们坚定的支持者
he was convinced we're gonna be broke artists I remember it actually was the Emmy for arrested development that when he finally went okay fine you guys can do this I think he's the one that set the ice cream right so so you guys do so so we you do arrested you guys direct the pilot and you direct most I would say the bulk of the episodes of the first two seasons nobody directed more episodes than you guys some of the great some of our favorite episodes obviously with you guys and and Jason I talked about this too all of us and you guys are part of you guys and me and Jason and the cast and Mitch and everybody we made those not John not John those first like eight episodes completely in a vacuum we had no
他坚信我们会成为身无分文的艺术家，我记得实际上是凭借《发展受阻》获得艾美奖时，他终于觉得“好吧，好吧，你们可以做这个”，我想是他准备了冰淇淋，对吧？所以你们做了，所以你们做，你们执导了试播集，而且你们执导了——我可以说——前两季绝大多数的剧集，没有人比你们执导的剧集更多了，其中一些精彩的剧集，我们最喜欢的剧集显然都是你们拍的，杰森我也谈过这个，我们所有人，你们，还有我、杰森、演员阵容、米奇以及所有人，我们完全在真空环境中制作了那些剧集，不是约翰，不是约翰，前八集完全是在与世隔绝的情况下拍的，我们根本
idea if people were gonna like him or think that they were shit and so we were kind of like this real tight group of us just doing it with no feedback and it's like and we're taking big swings and thought like fuck we could I remember driving home some days after shooting going like this might be the worst thing ever I had no further to fall I was like I was fine I'm comfortable on the bottom we have we have a lot of fun doing and then you guys and then the show ends and you guys end up sort of moving on and doing a bunch of other stuff what was the first when you kind of started to break out of the arrested world what were you guys thinking okay now we want to do X or Y what was the plan well
不知道人们会喜欢它还是觉得它是狗屎，所以我们就像是一个非常紧密的团队，在没有任何反馈的情况下完成它，感觉就像我们在进行大胆的尝试，心想“他妈的，我们可能会”，我记得有一天拍完戏开车回家时想，这可能是有史以来最糟糕的东西，我没有再往下掉的空间了，我觉得无所谓，我在谷底也很自在，我们做得很开心，然后你们，然后节目结束了，你们最终继续前进，做了一堆其他的事情，当你们开始从《发展受阻》的世界中走出来时，第一部作品是什么？你们当时在想什么？“好吧，现在我们想拍X或者Y”，当时的计划是什么？嗯
I think really what it was going on then we had struggled so long to sort of make a life is like any filmmakers and then kind of segue into television that once arrested had that success once we won the Emmy it was all of a sudden we had work coming at us for the first time in our lives like everything prior to that point was just like us pushing the boulder up the hill right like trying not to listen the people tell us no now it's chasing you yeah all of a sudden it was coming at us so we welcome that and we had we had a run in television there that ended up turning into shows like community and happy endings and right right a few other shows what our what our process would be was basically what
我想当时真正发生的情况是，我们为了谋生苦苦挣扎了那么久，就像任何电影人一样，然后顺理成章地进入了电视行业，一旦《发展受阻》取得了成功，一旦我们赢得了艾美奖，突然之间，我们生平第一次有了源源不断的工作找上门来，此前的一切就像是我们推着巨石上山一样，对吧？努力不去听别人对我们说“不”，现在是工作在追着你们跑，对，突然之间它们都向我们涌来，我们对此表示欢迎，我们在电视界有过一段经历，最终演变成了像《废柴联盟》和《幸福结局》这样的节目，对，对，还有其他一些节目，我们的流程基本上是
we did on arrested where we would come in we would direct a pilot because again we we had sort of patterned ourselves as sort of indie feature makers so we would approach a pilot like it was a feature sort of execute it like that and then we would stay on with the show for just like with arrested for a season or two and do some episodes and then kind of like pass it on normally the show would be canceled by that point but that became our process right and then what was it what was the first big film after your television run there Captain America for yeah what was it in between we did you mean to pray oh you don't need to be right right right right right yeah which I by the way which I also did the
我们在《发展受阻》时期的做法，我们会加入进来，执导一集试播集，因为同样地，我们把自己定位为独立故事片制作人，所以我们会像对待电影一样对待试播集，像那样去执行它，然后我们会像在《发展受阻》时一样，在剧组呆上一两季，拍几集，然后把它交接出去，通常节目到那个时候就会被取消了，但这就成了我们的流程，对，那么在那段电视生涯之后，你的第一部大电影是什么？为了《美国队长》，对，中间有什么作品？你是说，哦，你不需要说，对，对，对，对，对，对，我顺便说一句，我也参加了
table read of remember that that's right I played I think was Michael Douglas the in that yeah yeah I did I read his part of the table right that is very long and storied history mr. Arnett it's crazy right yeah I remember Downey calling me about you guys saying so so what do you think about the I remember getting that call going holy shit the russians are going to do a fucking Marvel movie yeah I remember thinking that quietly to myself because I didn't want to say it outwardly to do downy yeah I didn't want him to hear the surprise in my voice or envy but I just immediately went into like I got so excited thinking about you guys combining with his humor and his sensibility and his
剧本围读，还记得吗？没错，我演的好像是那部里的迈克尔·道格拉斯，对，对，我读了他那个角色的围读部分，那是相当漫长且传奇的历史啊，阿尔纳特先生，太疯狂了，对，我记得唐尼打电话给我，谈到你们时说：“所以，你们对……怎么看？”我记得接到那个电话时心想：“卧槽，罗素兄弟要去拍漫威电影了”，对，我当时在心里默默地这样想，因为我不想当着唐尼的面大声说出来，对，我不想让他听到我声音里的惊讶或嫉妒，但我立刻变得——我一想到你们要把他的幽默、他的敏感度与他的
comfort on set and you guys just the way you just move around to say I just thought I could I couldn't say enough about what a great match that would be I mean I'm not taking any claim for him signing off you know you should be completely surprised that he was calling about this is a great clickable story for the internet I'm happy to repeat that I'll tell you something the other side of that coin I mean there's a lot of truth in that because you know the first Captain America movie we did Winter Soldier Downey wasn't in it amazing then we went back with our partners Marcus and McFeely who who wrote all the Marvel work that we did and we conceived the next Captain America movie Civil War yeah you know Downey was never supposed
片场自如感结合在一起，以及你们移动和表达的方式，我就兴奋得不行，我简直无法用言语表达这是多么绝佳的契合，我的意思是，我可不居功说是因为他签约了，你知道的，你完全应该对他的来电感到惊讶，这是一个非常适合互联网点击的八卦故事，我很乐意重复一遍，我告诉你们一件事，硬币的另一面，我的意思是，这其中有很多真相，因为你知道，我们拍的第一部《美国队长》电影是《冬日战士》，唐尼没有参演，太棒了，然后我们和我们的合作伙伴马库斯与麦克菲利一起回归，他们写了我们所有的漫威作品，我们构思了下一部《美国队长》电影《内战》，对
to be in that movie he wasn't contracted to be in that movie but we had designed a story where it was built as a two-hander between Captain America and Downey's character Iron Man so we finally got the approval from Marvel Coven Feige said okay let's do this he got the approval from Marvel publishing in New York we're gonna do it and he said okay now you guys got to go get Downey he's like just tossed it tossed it to us that's an easy fish to boat yeah listen Robert we want you I know you've you know you've revitalized your career playing a superhero we want you to be the villain in this next one that was literally the pitch to him as we had to go sit there and explain to him you know how his you know
你知道，唐尼本来是不应该出现在那部电影里的，他没有签那部电影的合同，但我们设计了一个故事，将其构筑为美国队长和唐尼的角色钢铁侠之间的双主角戏，所以我们最终得到了漫威凯文·费奇的批准，他说：“好吧，我们干吧”，我们得到了纽约漫威出版部的批准，我们要拍了，他说：“好吧，现在你们得去搞定唐尼”，他就像是把球随手扔给了我们，这可不是个容易钓的鱼，对，听着，罗伯特，我们需要你，我知道你通过扮演超级英雄重振了你的职业生涯，我们想让你成为下一部电影里的反派，这就是对他的台词，我们不得不坐在那里向他解释，你知道他的（角色）
how his character wasn't going to be oh boy exclusively a villain in it so it's a big swing for him because yeah you know here are the guys coming off of Captain America doing it you know this is gonna be our second movie with Evans he's coming into Evans's franchise and it was a big it was a big swing and I'm stunned I'm still stunned he said yes well but he loves taking chances as you know and he's such a I would have loved to be in that meeting of you guys convincing him and I can imagine the questions that Downey asked you guys because he's so thoughtful and he's thinking from so many different steps ahead always inside way like in every direction right I just want to see his outfit I want to see I
他的角色在里面不会是——哦天哪——完全是个反派，所以对他的确是一次巨大的冒险，因为你知道，这是刚拍完《美国队长》的导演们在做这件事，你知道，这将是我们与埃文斯的第二部电影，他是走进埃文斯的系列电影，这是一次巨大的冒险，我感到震惊，我至今仍震惊他竟然答应了，嗯，但正如你所知，他喜欢冒险，他是一个——我真希望能在你们说服他的那场会议里，我可以想象唐尼问你们的问题，因为他心思缜密，总是从许多不同的未来步骤出发，在各个方向上深谋远虑，对，我只想看他的服装，我只想
want to know what what he was wearing he had us out to the house he might have been in shorts of a t-shirt Anthony remember he's kind of laying on a Shays lounge Anthony are sitting across from him leaning forward you know excitedly pitching and then this happens when sweating and then he almost kills you down you'll be wearing like a see-through Fendi raincoat he literally came to a barbecue well I know I cook out on the beach once and he was wearing a see-through Fendi raincoat and I go what the fuck are you wearing man but nobody can pull it off like Downey by the way he made it look cool like if I were I'd look like the worst he's a he's a walking piece of art he's a piece of art guys I have two questions
知道他穿的是什么，他让我们去他家，他可能穿着短裤和T恤，安东尼，记得吗？他有点躺在贵妃椅上，安东尼坐在他对面，身体前倾，兴奋地推销着，然后发生了这个，汗流浃背，然后他差点杀了你，唐尼当时穿着一件透视的芬迪雨衣，他去参加海滩烧烤时居然真的穿着一件透视的芬迪雨衣，我说：“你他妈到底穿的是什么啊，老兄？”但没有人能像唐尼那样把这衣服穿出效果，顺便说一句，他把它穿得很酷，如果我穿的话，我会看起来像最糟糕的，他是一个行走的艺术品，他是一个艺术品，伙计们，我有两个问题
I have two questions about end game really quick yeah one is I'm sure you've seen the reactions on tiktok and everything I think the crowd reaction videos and about end game it must have been like so satisfying and thrilling and like that was just huge that's the first question and then the second thing is how in the world one of the most now iconic shots in all of cinema history is all of those superheroes in one shot when Iron Man dies and they're all lined up and the camera goes through every single one of them and what'd you say what'd you say nothing what did he say I guess I don't need to see that I want the 18 years old no I said but no show it have you still managed to scrape the jizz off your TV from
我关于《终局之战》有两个问题，非常快，对，一个是，我确信你们看过TikTok和其他地方的反应视频，我想关于《终局之战》的观众反应视频，那一定非常满足、惊心动魄，而且就像——那真是太宏大了，这是第一个问题；第二个问题是，世界上怎么会有——现在电影史上最具标志性的镜头之一，就是所有那些超级英雄都在一个镜头里，当钢铁侠死时，他们排成一列，镜头掠过他们每一个人，你说了什么？你说了什么？什么都没说，他说什么了？我想我不需要看那个，我要18岁的——不，我说的是，不，展示出来，你们还设法把精液从你的电视上擦掉了吗？
it no it makes everybody look beautiful yeah and so anyway so it goes through and the camera goes through and every single superhero ever like in every single movie how I had somebody in the business watching I'm like how did you organize everybody's schedule to shoot all that's so many schedules to figure out we start with number two first yeah that took a year wait that took a year planning just that shot yeah and we referred to it as the wedding I mean it took us a year to plan how to get all those people together and then we had we had a couple months to plan out that shot but I remember the day that we yeah we took a we sent a drone up just to get a footage of base camp that day I've never seen
不，这让每个人看起来都很美，所以不管怎样，它掠过去了，镜头掠过了每一个超级英雄，就像每一部电影里的一样，我当时看的时候心里想：“你们是怎么安排每个人的档期来拍这一切的？有那么多档期需要协调，”我们先从第二点开始，对，那花了整整一年，等等，光是筹备那个镜头就花了一年时间，对，我们把它称为“婚礼”，我的意思是，我们花了一年时间来筹备如何把所有人聚在一起，然后我们有几个月的时间来规划那个镜头，但我记得我们——我们放飞了一架无人机，只是为了拍一点那天大本营的素材，我从来没见过
anything like it it was everybody said it was the largest base camp they'd ever seen in really 40 or 50 it went on for miles I mean it was in excess of 50 trucks oh it was it was it was it was the deal points Olympics I bet oh portal to portal meeting trailer requirements food and right just workout trailer everything oh my god but we rehearsed that shot Sean we did we like we scouted that location multiple times we got we brought stand-ins we would do we rehearsed the entire shot over and over so that it was we refined it we refined it because it was amazing I mean name an actor and they were in that shot it was crazy it was a lot of pressure it was and I remember yeah that day we were able to shoot that on
那样的事情，每个人都说那是他们见过的最大的大本营，真的，有40或50个，绵延好几英里，我的意思是，有超过50辆卡车，哦，那简直就是合同条款奥运会，我敢打赌，哦，大门到大门的会议、拖车需求、食物，还有，纯粹的健身拖车，应有尽有，哦天哪，但我们排练过那个镜头，肖恩，我们多次实地考察那个地点，我们找了替身，我们会做——我们一遍又一遍地排练整个镜头，以便将其精细化，我们不断精细化，因为它太棒了，我的意思是，说出一个演员的名字，他们就在那个镜头里，这太疯狂了，压力太大了，而且我记得，对，那天我们得以在亚特兰大郊外的一个牧场上拍摄
a on a ranch down and outside of Atlanta so we had control of the property there was no paparazzi around right it was a several hundred acres so it was you know very clandestine and you to get on the set that day was the most you know intense security you had to be at the highest level sort of the I'm sure and how long did it take to actually film the scene I think it took us about two hours I probably did that shot like eight or nine times you know you're only getting people stand around for so long because you know they're not really doing anything they gotta get back to the cable machine and so impressive last backs and buys yeah well it interrupts a lot of workouts yeah those fan reaction
所以我们控制了那片地产，周围没有狗仔队，对，有几百英亩，所以你知道，非常秘密，那天进入片场是最高级别的，你知道的，极其紧张的安保，你必须达到最高级别的安全水平，我敢肯定，实际拍摄这个场景花了多长时间？我想我们大概花了两小时，那个镜头我大概拍了八九次，你知道的，你只能让人们站在那里那么久，因为他们实际上没做什么，他们得回去用钢缆机锻炼，所以印象深刻，最后的背部和肱二头肌训练，哦，这确实打断了很多人的锻炼，那些粉丝反应
videos to show that you brought up we've watched those things so much I mean there are some of the most satisfying things we've ever seen you know I mean to be to see a movie theater you know to a crowd to react like that in a movie theater there's not a live show yeah it's just was extremely rare and it's for people who just like love that experience in the theater it's just was priceless yeah and my my god you know growing up for for me it was like you know Star Wars because I'm not Star Wars was the thing but my one of my godson Sammy he was like crying his eyes out when Iron Man died and I was you know and he called me he's like I'm like what's matter he's like Iron Man is dead I'm like
你们提到的那些视频，我们看了无数遍，我的意思是，那是我们见过的最令人满足的事情之一，你知道，在电影院里看到一部电影，看到观众在电影院里做出那样的反应，这不是现场演出，极其罕见，对于那些单纯热爱影院观影体验的人来说，那是无价的，天哪，你知道，对我成长过程中来说，就像是《星球大战》，因为我不是——《星球大战》就是那种东西，但我的教子之一萨米，当钢铁侠死时，他哭得稀里哗啦，而我，你知道的，他打电话给我，他说：“怎么了？”他说：“钢铁侠死了”，我说
it was such a huge deal for this massive generation of these fans in a way that star it was just so cool to see like it sounds like Sammy needs to get a life to be honest yeah I might want to take a step outside perspective you know Sammy I mean some bad parenting or something but but let me ask you guys no JK we love Sammy what about your own kids and their reactions to you guys being part of something that is so such a huge part of I'm sure their friends and everybody loves the movies and and and they do too and can they appreciate it in the way knowing that you know what you got that you guys made these movies it's a really complex question yeah I think it's like you know the same movies that took us away for
这对这庞大的一代粉丝来说是一件大事，以至于星战——看到这一幕真是太酷了，听起来萨米需要去找个生活，说实话，对，我可能想换个角度来看待这件事，你知道，萨米，我的意思是，这背后可能有些糟糕的育儿方式什么的，但是，等等，让我问你们一个问题，不开玩笑，我们爱萨米，你们自己的孩子呢？对于你们参与了这样一部在他们的朋友和每个人心中都占据如此巨大分量的作品，他们的反应是怎样的？我确信他们的朋友和所有人都喜欢这些电影，他们也喜欢，他们能以这种方式去欣赏它吗？知道你们制作了这些电影，这是一个非常复杂的问题，对，我想这就像，你知道，同样的电影让我们离开
two years you know but they're my kids are not big comic book fans so it was interesting it's grounding because you come home and they could give a shit you know which is great I think and you know but I do think that you know for Anthony look we we you said this earlier Bateman we were huge comic book fans and we nobody knew this but I have a you know I have like five boxes and an attic still filled with you know 50 year old comic books this was a dream come true for us and what you're talking about Sean is watching these reactions in the theaters that's who we were as kids yeah I watched Empire Strikes Back yeah like five times in a row and one day yeah sitting in the front row by myself you
两年，你知道，但我的孩子们不是什么超级漫画迷，所以这很有趣，这很接地气，因为你回到家，他们根本不在乎，你知道的，这挺好的，我认为，你知道，但对于安东尼，你看，我们——你刚才说过，贝特曼，我们曾经是超级漫画迷，没有人知道这一点，但我（在阁楼里）还有大约五个箱子里装满了50年前的漫画书，这对于我们来说是梦想成真，肖恩你刚才提到在影院里看这些反应，我们小时候就是那样的人，对，我看了五遍《帝国反击战》
know crying at the end every time that was me masturbating behind you check out this lightsaber put it this way Joe he wasn't watching the movie but to be able to give that to like you want to recreate that experience that's what we wanted that's what we love about film so there's a line you could draw from who we were as kids to these movies right and that's like falling out of his booth right now cracks himself up all the time turn him down in the mix and you just keep talking and we will be right back smart let's get support from Viori clothing Viori clothing it feels so good tired of sacrificing style for comfort or vice versa look no further than Viori the performance clothing brand
连续看了五遍，有一天，一个人坐在第一排，每次到结局都在哭，那个人就是我，在你身后手淫，看看这把光剑，把它拿开，这么说吧，乔，他当时根本没在看电影，但能把那种体验带给——你想重现那种体验，这就是我们想要的，这就是我们热爱电影的原因，所以你可以从我们小时候的身份画一条线到这些电影，对吧？现在他正从座位上笑得前仰后合，他总是把自己逗笑，把他的麦克风声音调小，你们继续聊，我们马上回来，智能精选，让我们来看看Viori服装的赞助，Viori服装，穿起来太舒服了，厌倦了为了舒适而牺牲时尚，反之亦然吗？找Viori就对了，这个运动服品牌
that combines both Viori offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet making it the perfect investment in your happiness from joggers to leggings to crew necks Viori has everything you need to stay comfy and stylish no matter what you're doing I always wear my Viori almost every day if not every other day I'll wear to the theater because I like to feel comfortable before I go and then when the show's over and I take all my makeup off I take my costume off and I get everything done I put it back on because it feels so cozy it feels like oh I'm out of like my work clothes back into my comfy clothes it feels so good for our listeners they're offering 20% off your first purchase
兼具时尚与舒适。Viori提供地球上最舒适、最百搭的服装，绝对是对你幸福感的完美投资。从慢跑裤、打底裤到圆领衫，Viori应有尽有，无论你在做什么，都能让你保持舒适和时尚。我几乎每天都穿Viori，如果不是每天，也会隔天穿一次。我会穿着它去剧院，因为我喜欢在出门前感到舒适，然后在演出结束、卸完妆、脱下戏服、一切都忙完后，我又会穿上它，因为它穿起来太舒服了，感觉就像“哦，我脱下了工作服，换回了舒适的衣服”，感觉棒极了。为了回馈我们的听众，他们为你的首次购买提供20%的折扣。
get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori dot com slash smart list that's V U O R I dot com slash smart list not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any US orders over $75 and free returns go to Viori dot com slash smart list and discover the versatility of Viori clothing smart list is sponsored by better help so this past week I opened my Broadway show and it went really well and but the lead up to it was a lot of work a lot of being there for lots of people and while I love doing that it can build up inside of you and you kind of like need a break and I'm sure you guys can relate to whoever is
快去 Viori.com/smartlist 选购地球上最舒适、最百搭的服装吧。网址是 V U O R I dot com 斜杠 smartlist。你不仅可以享受首次购买的20%折扣，还能享受美国境内订单满75美元免运费和免费退货的优惠。快去 Viori.com/smartlist，发现 Viori 服装的百搭魅力吧。《SmartLess》由 BetterHelp 赞助。就在过去这周，我的百老汇演出首演了，进展非常顺利，但在那之前有大量的工作，有很多时间陪伴许多人，虽然我很喜欢这样做，但这种情绪会在你内心积压，你需要休息一下，我相信你们以及听节目的各行各业的朋友们都能感同身受，在工作中你常常需要照顾别人，一段时间后压力积压，你需要留出时间给自己，也许是一个周末，也许是一个星期天，或者任何能让你重置状态的方法，这样你才能再次为每个人付出。我想每个人都有这种感受，我并非孤例。
listening to your line of work where you're kind of there for people at your job and after a while it builds up and you need to take some time for yourself maybe the weekend maybe on a Sunday or just anything you can just to kind of reset so that you can be there again for everybody and I think everybody feels that I don't think I'm alone in that so and it's it's so easy to get caught up in what everyone else needs from you and never take a moment to think about what you need from yourself and while it can feel selfish at times it is not it is the opposite it is so that you can continue to be there for people which is what I love to do but when we spend all of our time giving it can lead us feeling
人们很容易陷入满足所有人对你的需求的泥潭，却从不花时间想想自己需要什么。虽然有时会觉得自私，但其实并非如此，恰恰相反，这样做是为了让你能够继续陪伴在大家身边，这也是我喜欢做的事。然而，当我们把所有时间都用来奉献时，往往会感到筋疲力尽、精疲力竭。正如我所说，心理治疗可以为你提供工具，在生活中找到更多平衡，这样你就能继续支持他人，而不会抛弃自我。我以前经常谈到这一点，当我觉得自己的“杯子”——或者说我的“杯子”被照顾他人装满了，却没有先照顾自己时，是时候通过倾诉来宣泄了。和别人聊聊就像稍微打开了压力阀，让你能自己喘口气。找个人聊聊确实很有帮助，能帮你重新找回平衡。所以，如果你正在考虑开始心理治疗，不妨试试 BetterHelp。它完全在线，旨在
stretched thin and burned out like I said therapy can give you the tools to find more balance in your life so you can keep supporting others without leaving yourself behind so I've talked about this a lot before is when I am feeling like kind of like my my my glasses filled to the brim with with being there for other people instead of myself first it's time to get it out by talking to somebody and in talking to somebody kind of just releases the pressure valve a little bit and so you can get some air to breathe on your own it really really does help to to speak to somebody to to balance yourself again so if you're thinking about starting therapy give better help a try it's entirely online designed
提供便利、灵活且适合你的日程安排。只需填写一份简短的问卷，就能与有资质的治疗师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换治疗师。如果你想通过 BetterHelp 寻找更多平衡，请访问 betterhelp.com/smartlist，首次月度订阅可享 10% 的折扣。网址是 betterhelp.com/smartlist（help 拼写为 H-E-L-P）。本期《SmartLess》部分内容由梅西百货（Macy's）赞助播出。母亲节马上就要到了，通过挑选她正想要的礼物向妈妈表达爱意吧。她是美妆达人、健身搭子、巧克力控，还是兼而有之？梅西百货的礼物搜寻器（Gift Finder）能轻松根据妈妈的喜好定制你的礼物搜寻。快来 macys.com/giftfinder 探索这些绝佳的购物方式以及更多灵感。
to be convenient flexible and suited to your schedule just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge if you want find more balance with better help visit better help comm slash smart list today to get 10% off your first month that's better help H ELP comm slash smart list this episode of smart list is brought to you in part by Macy's mother's day is practically here give some love to mom by finding exactly what she wants is she a beauty icon workout buddy chocoholic or all of the above Macy's makes it so easy to tailor your gift hunt to mom's tastes with their gift finder check out these great ways to shop and more inspo
（接上条）那么我打算在梅西百货给妈妈送什么礼物呢？除非梅西百货有生命的礼物，否则我做不到，我妈妈已经去世了，但谢天谢地，我岳母还在，她过得很好，我很爱她，她太棒了。如果你已经知道妈妈喜欢收集手提包，渴望一套配套的睡衣，或者正在寻找一款新的标志性香水，你可以按礼物类别或礼物清单进行购物。梅西百货提供独特精选的礼物清单，比如专为应有尽有的妈妈或岳母准备的清单、已经包装好随时可以送人的礼物，以及为奶奶准备的礼物。如果妈妈或岳母喜欢设计师品牌，你可以找到她最喜欢的品牌的最新单品，无论是对蔻驰手提包、
at Macy's comm slash gift finder so what am I planning on gifting my mom at Macy's unless Macy's has the gift of life I can't my mother is dead but my mother in law is still with us thank God and she's doing great and I love her and she's fantastic if you already know that mom loves adding to her handbag collection a door is a matching PJ set or is looking for a new signature scent shop by gift category or shop by gift lists Macy's has unique curated gift lists like for the mom or mother-in-law who has everything gifts that are already wrapped and ready to be gifted and for grandma and if mom or mother-in-law loves designer names find the latest from her most adored brands whether she's loyal to coach handbags
迪奥香水还是古德迪夫巧克力情有独钟，梅西百货应有尽有。快前往 macys.com/giftfinder，让这个母亲节成为一个特别难忘的日子吧。现在，让我们回到节目中。你们刚开始作为导演起步时，拍一些小成本电影时，有没有得到过什么建议，直到今天你们还在用在那些大规模的项目上？还是说，作为导演，你们已经改变了太多、适应了太多，以至于一开始学到的一切现在都不大适用了？或者说，有没有什么永不过时的经验？不要和杰森·贝特曼合作，除了那条之外。除了吸取那个教训之外，我的意思是，简单来说，我认为对
to your perfume or good dive at chocolates Macy's has all her top faves head on over to Macy's comm slash gift finder to make this mother's day and especially memorable one and now back to the show did you guys get any advice when you were first starting out as directors you know doing films at a tiny scale that's that you're still using today on stuff that you're doing in a massive scale are you or if you change so much as directors had to adapt so much as directors that everything you learned at the beginning is not really applicable now or or is there some evergreen don't work with Jason Bateman was not aside from that one aside from that lesson learned I mean look at the short answer I think for
我们而言，因为我们做过那么多不同的事情——我们拍过预算极其有限的电影，也拍过预算极其庞大的电影；我们做过电视剧、喜剧、正剧、电视网、有线电视、流媒体、鞋类广告——所以对我们来说，因为我们喜欢在所有这些不同的形式中工作，这一切其实都一样，无论我们在做什么，我们的流程都是一样的，我们只是构思出让我们兴奋的东西，然后想办法把它拍出来。所以这基本上就是那个流程一遍又一遍地重复。因此，我认为，而且我们热爱科技，我们一直很喜欢科技
us is like because we've done so many different things like we've made movies for as little money as you could possibly make a movie for and we've made movies for as much money as you can make a movie for you know we've done TV comedy drama you know network cable streaming we do shoe commercials so it's like for us you know because we like working in all these different forms it's kind of all the same for like we have the same process no matter what we're doing we just sort of dream up with something that's exciting to us and then figure out how to execute it so it's kind of just that process repeated over and over again so I think and we love technology we we've always loved the the way the technology
能让你创造出某种感觉或效果的方式，或者——你们是怎么跟上这一点的？因为我确信，你知道，如果你能想象得到，现在你就能把它做出来，但你们怎么能确定呢？你们是如何紧跟科技发展的，以便知道你们脑海中的想法实际上是否可行？这很难，因为你必须去使用它，所以这真的很棘手，你必须找出学习它的方法，你必须不断学习，而学习它的唯一方法就是使用它。我的意思是，电影制作是数百人之间巨大的合作，所以你要依靠技术专家、科技人员，他们会进来向你展示正在发生的新事物，告诉你关于……
allows you to create certain feelings or effects or or or just how do you stay up on that because I'm sure that you know if you can imagine it you can do it nowadays but how do you know that for sure how do you stay up on on where technology is so that you know whether what you're thinking of is actually manageable it's hard because you have to use it so it is really tricky you have to just figure out ways to learn it to you have to constantly learn the only way to learn it is to use it yeah I mean filmmaking was a giant collaboration between hundreds of people so you're relying on you know technical experts technologists that come in and can show you new things that are going on tell you about you know farrows
法夫罗是我们非常好的朋友，他做过所有这些不可思议的工作，对，带着《星球大战》的剧集使用LED屏幕，真正努力推进这项工艺，使其更有效率，而重要的事情是，科技能帮到你的地方在于，你知道，预算越高，风险就越高，当你在一个项目上花更多钱时，制片厂就会变得更厌恶风险。如果你能把那个数字降下来，他们就会承担更多风险，他们就会对有有趣声音的电影人、年轻的电影人冒风险。我认为这至关重要，因为讲故事的成本已经变得荒谬地昂贵，未来必须出现一个数字能
are really good friend of ours and he's you know he's done all this incredible work yeah with Star Wars shows using LED screens and really trying to advance the craft to make it more efficient and it's important thing is where technology helps you is you know the higher the budget goes the higher the risk right and then a studio becomes more risk averse when you're spending more money on a project if you can get that number down then they'll take more risks then they'll take risks on you know filmmakers with interesting voices younger filmmakers I think it's critically important because the it has gotten absurdly expensive to make to tell stories and there has to be a future where that number comes
大幅下降的局面。但尽管你这么说，你们在亚马逊的新项目《堡垒》看起来——预告片棒极了，顺便说一句，你们在制作一部剧，给我们讲讲这部剧，但令我兴奋的是，你们在制作这部剧时，制作了多个版本的剧集，它们在世界不同的地区相互交织、互相呼应，对，解释一下这一点。好吧，基本上是因为珍·萨尔基来找我们，她负责亚马逊，说：“听着，我有这个想法，这基本上是一个商业模式”，也就是，我想制作一部美国母舰剧，它能以某种方式与全球各地的各种本地语言剧集联系起来，母舰英语剧集与本地语言剧集之间存在互动，
down dramatically but but while you say that it your new project Citadel on on Amazon seems to be the trailers incredible by the way the you're you're doing a show tell tell tell us a little bit about the show but what's exciting to me is that you're doing it in you're doing multiple versions of the show that kind of cross pollinate each other like in different territories around the world yeah explain that I mean basically it came from Jen Salki came to us who runs Amazon and said look I have this idea it's basically a business model yeah which is I want to do a us mothership show that somehow connects to various local language shows around the globe in some in some manner there's interplay
她问：“你们能想出什么点子吗？”我们喜欢这个想法，因为我们热爱全球观众，这是漫威经历真正启发我们的地方之一。我的意思是，我们一生都是具有全球视野的，自从我们成为早期的电影迷以来就是这样，但你知道，我们生活在一个这样的世界里：你可以通过一个故事触及全球每个角落的人，让他们同时一起享受并进行交流，我的意思是，这真的是一件非常强大的事情。所以我们想，好吧，这是一个新前沿，这是新科技，亚马逊现在存在了，他们的商业模式说：“哦，我们可以制作不同语言、世界不同地方的节目，它们可以相互交流。”
between the mothership English language show and the local language shows and she's like can you guys come up with anything we love the idea because we love the global audience that was one thing that the Marvel experience really turned us on to I mean we were globally minded all of our lives since we were like early film fans but you know the idea that we live in a world now where you can reach people in every corner of the globe with a story that they can enjoy together at the same time and communicate together I mean it's just a really it's a very powerful thing so we thought okay this is a new frontier this is new technology Amazon now exists and their business model says oh we can make shows
哇，而且演员阵容也会互相客串，没错，他们也可以互相客串，你们在创造——你说“客串”啊，太恶心了，你真对这个词念念不忘，我迫不及待想看了。好，我们制作了这个节目，这是我们的公司AGBO制作的——你知道，自从我们离开漫威后，乔和我一直能够——我们与我们的合作伙伴克里斯·马库斯和史蒂夫·麦克菲利（他们是编剧伙伴）成立了一家制作公司。“AGBO”是什么意思，快说。AGP，什么都不是，绝对什么都不是，又是无意义的词。去拿那瓶啤酒，乔，我要答案。不，听着，最简短的
in different languages in different places around the world and they can talk to one another wow and cast members kind of cross pollinate as well that's right they can cross pollinate also you're creating up saying pollinate yeah there's something so gross you really hung up on that I can't wait to see it yeah well and we produce this is show we produce this is something that our company Agbo you know we were Joe and I have been able to since we moved on from the Marvel we formed a production company with our partners Chris Marcus and Steve McFeely who are writing partners what's Agbo mean real quick AGP nothing absolutely nothing it's nonsense again go get that beer Jill I want the answer no here the shortest
答案是，当我们刚开始一起写作并开始做一些素描喜剧时，我们试图为它炒作，所以我们在学校校报上写了一篇文章，是对该节目的虚假评论，评论员对该节目大加鞭挞，他讨厌该节目的地方正是我们喜欢该节目的地方，我们需要为这篇文章起个名字，我们在克利夫兰电话簿里查到一个叫AGBO的人，太搞笑了，哇，好吧，你们有没有想过——顺便说一句，刚才说到“客串”——你们有没有想过涉足《星球大战》的世界？有没有这方面的计划？你本来想说想涉足戏剧，我真的很想做音乐剧，我知道这会引发后续，好吧，那将是一个——我们热爱《星球大战》，我的意思是，这你知道的——你不会透露任何你开过会的、正在谈论的事情，因为你不能谈论它。有过早期对话，我们和凯文·费奇之间有过早期对话，凯文·费奇是《星球大战》的超级粉丝，我们曾有过一些早期对话，关于可能与凯文合作拍摄《星球大战》。
answer that is when we were when we were first writing together and we started doing some sketch comedy we tried to drum up publicity for it so we wrote an article for the school newspaper that was a phony review of the show and the reviewer just lacerates the show and everything he hates about the show is everything we love about the show and we needed a name for this article we looked in the Cleveland phone book and found some guy named goes the Agbo that's hysterical wow all right have you guys ever wanted to dive by the way started back up for saying have you guys ever wanted to dive into the Star Wars world is there plans to do such you're gonna say want to dive into theater I really want to do specifically
借鉴杰森的话，之间有很多客串，哦，现在他醒了，在《星球大战》和漫威之间，很多相同的——因为它的感觉有点类似于——星战蜂巢思维，对，这两个世界之间的感觉很相似，所以曾经有人两边都涉足过是顺理成章的，我敢打赌，如果我是凯瑟琳·肯尼迪，我会想：“太好了，我要给罗素兄弟打电话，我也想让他们加入进来。”没能谈成合作，绝对的，很贵，好吧，现在不是了，这些家伙正在统治世界。但让我问你这个，所以你是粉丝，如果有事情发生，那就太棒了，他们是粉丝，他们公开承认自己是粉丝，顺便说一句，主动权在他们手里，对，所以你们，我的意思是，“他们”指的是《星球大战》。所以你们，你们拍了所有这些漫威电影，然后你们去拍了一堆大电影，你们拍了一些跟大牌演员合作的电影，和瑞恩·高斯林、埃文斯合作了《灰影人》，
musical theater I know it's coming to follow up well that will be a we love we love Star Wars I mean this is you know the same way that you're not gonna say anything that you've had meetings on that you're talking about because he can't talk about it there were early conversations there were early conversations with us and you know Kevin Feige is a huge Star Wars fan and there were some early conversations about maybe teaming up with Kevin to do Star Wars speaking to take from Jason there's been a lot of cross-pollination yeah between oh now he's awake between Star Wars and Marvel a lot of the same because it doesn't have a sort of a similar to start bees yeah similar sensibility right between between those two
和汤姆·霍兰德合作了……当你们拍完那个世界再去拍这些电影时，它们是不是看起来容易得多？因为正如肖恩所说，为了《终局之战》，你们花了一年时间规划一个镜头，他妈的，你们做了所有这些事，里面包含了那么多心血，现在当你们拍一部普普通通的动作喜剧或别的什么时，你们会觉得“那挺容易的”，这是你开始的——我的意思是，乔，你写了《灰影人》，对吧？没错，对，我们开始——你看，我们在漫威之后的转变更多是朝着艺术家所有权方向发展，我们想创办自己的公司，我们想开始控制、尽可能多地创造我们自己的内容，
worlds so it makes sense that there have been people who have done both and I bet you if I'm Kathy Kennedy I'm like yeah I'm calling the Russo brothers because I want them to get in here too yeah couldn't make their deal guaranteed it's expensive well not now these guys are running the world but let me ask you this so you're a fan but if something happens it's great they're fans they're on the record is saying they're fans and by the way and the balls in their court yeah so you guys I mean by them I mean Star Wars so you guys you you do all this Marvel said you and then you go off you make a bunch of big movies you guys made some some movies with great man great made gossing in Evans yeah great man
我们出去在制片厂筹集资金，进行融资，有点像本（阿弗莱克）和马特（达蒙）正在做的那样，对，这有点像——你知道，对我们来说，我的意思是，我认为，你知道，这是业内一个颠覆性的时代，能有一个你可以受到保护的地方，对，你可以保护自己，你可以做你想做的工作，按照你想要的节奏工作，雇佣你自己，基本上就是这样，你知道，所以这是我们的焦点，看，成为你自己作品的粉丝，做你自己的粉丝，雇佣你自己，这就是你们在身后嘟囔的，乔，在电影院里，雇佣你自己，做你自己的粉丝。嘿，你们两个花多少时间——我知道你们一直在说“客串”，你们刚出道时是年轻电影人，你们得到了史蒂芬·索德伯格的认可或赏识，你们花多少时间去寻找那些年轻的新秀和年轻的声音？因为外面有很多人试图拍电影，或者正在拍电影并把它们放到网上等等，就像索德伯格对你们做的那样，对，你们花很多时间做那件事吗？寻找崭露头角的人才？
all those guys cherry with Tom Holland yeah when you go and you do those movies after coming out of that world do they just seem so much easier because like you you do like to Sean was saying for endgame you plan a shot for a year and you fucking and you do all this stuff and there's so much into it now when you make it just a regular old sort of action comedy or whatever you like that's pretty easy it's something you're starting I mean Joe you wrote a great man right that's right yeah we started I mean look the transition for us after Marvel was more towards artist ownership you know we wanted to start our own company we wanted to start you know controlling creating our own content as much as possible
当然，绝对的，那是AGBO议程的重要组成部分，因为我们能够——这家公司建立的方式是一个资金充足的公司，它制作大型项目，我们有能力和空间，乔和我也将此视为我们亏欠宇宙的 karmic debt（因果债），你知道，去寻找那些有才华、有重要故事要讲的有趣艺术家，并想方设法让这些电影变成现实，因为其中一些故事无法通过其他任何方式进入这个系统，对，你知道的，就像我们本来也无法通过其他任何方式进入这个系统一样，所以这对我们来说非常重要，事实上，你看，《瞬息全宇宙》是一个——恭喜，谢谢你们，想谈谈那个，你知道，对你们所有人的一个美妙之夜，太不可思议了，太宏大了，他们，我的意思是，他们
we went out and raised money in the studio as well finance kind of like what Ben and Matt are doing yeah exactly it's sort of a you know for us I mean I think you know it's a very disruptive time in the business and to have a place where you can be protected right you can protect yourself and you can work on what you want to work on and at the pace that you want to work on hire yourself and basically exactly and you know so that was the focus for us look for you to be a fan of your own work be a fan of your own hire yourself that's what you're all mumbling behind you Joe in the movie theater hire you're a fan of yourself just be a fan of yourself hey do you guys how much time do you guys
我们去为工作室筹集资金，进行融资，有点像本和马特正在做的那样。对，完全是这样。对我们来说，我的意思是，我认为这是一个行业中非常颠覆的时期，能有一个让你受到保护的地方，对吧？你可以保护自己，你可以做你想做的工作，以你想要的节奏，雇用你自己，基本上就是这样。所以，这才是我们的重点：让自己成为自己作品的粉丝，成为自己雇主的粉丝。你在后面嘟囔什么呢，乔？在电影院里做自己的粉丝，只要做自己的粉丝就行了。嘿，你们俩花多少时间
spend I know you keep saying talk about pollinate did you when you when you you guys came out you were young filmmakers and you and you were recognized or you were just sort of discovered if you will by Stephen Soderbergh but how much time do you guys spend looking for those new young talents and young voices because there are a lot of people out there who who are trying to make or or are making films and putting them online etc etc like what Soderbergh did for you guys yeah are you guys do you guys spend a lot of time doing that stuff looking for emerging talent yeah absolutely I mean that's a big part of our agenda at Agbo we and because we're able to you know the company is built in a way it's a well
我知道你们一直在说“孵化”。当你们刚出道时，你们是年轻的电影制作人，得到了史蒂芬·索德伯格的认可，或者说可以说是被他发掘的。那么，你们花多少时间去寻找那些年轻的新锐人才和年轻的声音呢？因为有很多人都在试图拍电影，或者正在拍电影并将它们发布到网上等等，就像索德伯格对你们做的那样。是的，你们会花很多时间做这种事，寻找新锐人才吗？当然会。我的意思是，这是我们 Agbo 公司议程中的重要部分。因为我们能够……这家公司建立的方式是一个资金充足的
funded company it makes large projects we have the capacity in the space and Joe and I also look at it as like we it's a karmic debt that we owe the universe right to like find people who are interesting artists who have important stories to tell and figure out how how we realize those movies because some of those stories aren't going to get through the system any other way right you know like we wouldn't have got through the system any other way so that's really important to us and in fact I mean look everything everywhere all at once is a congratulations way thank you wanted to get to that you know it's such a great night for all you guys yeah that's unbelievable massive they're I mean they're
公司，它制作大型项目。我们有足够的产能和空间，而且乔和我也有同感，觉得我们对宇宙有一种亏欠的因果债，要去寻找那些有趣的、有重要故事要讲述的艺术家，并想方设法将这些电影拍出来，因为其中有些故事如果没有这种体制是绝无可能拍出来的，对吧？你知道的，就像我们自己的故事如果没有这种体制也绝无可能拍出来一样。所以这对外我们来说非常重要。事实上，看看《瞬息全宇宙》吧，恭喜，谢谢。我想聊聊那个，对你们所有人来说都是个多么棒的夜晚啊。那真是难以置信，巨大无比，他们是……我的意思是，他们
incredibly talented and that's sort of part of the I mean these are guys that made a movie with the farting corpse you know they're risk takers they're very Swiss army man you guys ever see Swiss army man three callbacks for that yeah yeah but that's a good I mean there's a good because his because his resume is always said can fart on Q special skills try it count me down I'll do it juggles now what what can you can you tell us at all what maybe not specifically but in the world of what might be next that we can be all looking forward to seeing coming out of you guys so Citadel comes out very shortly extraction to is out in June nice Hemsworth franchise action another little cute little Andy you guys do that's
真的非常有才华，这就是其中的一部分，我的意思是，这些人拍了一部有放屁尸体的电影，你知道他们是敢于冒险的人，他们非常适合《瑞士军刀男》，你们看过《瑞士军刀男》吗？有三次试镜回调是关于那个的，对，对，但这是一个好主意，我的意思是，这是一个好主意，因为他的简历上一直写着“能随时放屁，有特殊技能”，试一下，倒计时，我会做的，现在开始杂耍，现在你能告诉我们，也许不是具体地说，在接下来可能会有什么，我们可以期待看到你们带来的作品吗？所以《堡垒》很快就要上映了，《惊天营救2》在六月上映，太棒了，海姆斯沃斯的动作片特许经营，另一个你们做的小可爱，那是
right and then Anthony are working on a project called the electric state that was starring Chris Pratt and Millie Bobby Brown with Pratt that's a mistake that's a mistake yeah you might want to re-consider with Pratt guys the movies already shot it's in the cance oh yeah by the way I ran into Chris the other day and he said he had the best time making that movie we we love Pratt I mean obviously look at a lot though see what I did but he's like you guys you guys know him so he's the greatest so he's he's he's just brought amazing energy every day he's always looking he's always searching he's always sort of surprising you and he's a very smooth good dude happy to be there but and you said something right
对的，然后安东尼正在做一个名为《电州》的项目，由克里斯·帕拉特和米莉·波比·布朗主演，和帕拉特一起，那是个错误，那是个错误，是的，你可能想重新考虑和帕拉特合作，伙计们，电影已经拍完了，已经杀青了，哦，对了，顺便说一句，我前几天遇到克里斯，他说他拍那部电影度过了最棒的时光，我们爱帕拉特，我的意思是，很明显，看看很多，但我明白了，但他就像你们一样，你们了解他，所以他是最棒的，所以他，他，他每天都带来惊人的能量，他总是在寻找，总是在探索，总是在某种程度上给你带来惊喜，他是一个非常随和的好人，很高兴能在那里，但是，你刚才说了一些话
there which is and I've always loved Pratt for this from the day I met him from the day he did that we talked about it we had him on the show and he did the first season of I know he was in Parks and Rec but the I remember the first season the first time I saw he was so surprising and he always is surprising yeah and so the ultimate weapon in comedy is that you never know what the fuck Pratt is gonna say or do yeah and and he catches you off guard and it's always really fucking funny and that's the mark of somebody who's genuinely funny and a great golfer you know he's decent he's decent he's decent let's not give him too much it works too much to be to be fantastic well I'm realizing as you
在那里，那就是——我一直为此而喜欢帕拉特，从我认识他的第一天起，从他做这件事的第一天起，我们谈论过，我们邀请他上节目，他做了第一季的……我知道他演过《公园与游憩》，但我记得第一季，我第一次看到他时，他是如此令人惊讶，而且他总是那么令人惊讶，是的，所以喜剧中的终极武器就是你永远不知道帕拉特这混蛋会说出什么或做出什么，是的，而且他让你措手不及，而且总是他妈的真的很好笑，这是一个真正有趣的人和一个高尔夫球手的标志，你知道，他还可以，他还可以，他还可以，我们不要给他太多赞誉了，他已经付出了很多努力才变得如此出色，好吧，我意识到正如你
know we do tend to work with a lot of the same actors we're you know we like family we like hanging out we like having fun it's you spend a lot of time on set together but I think we've worked with you probably double what we've worked with anyone else on so I think we've done like six or seven things together yeah only once with me and nothing was shown yeah so I'll double check my email yeah I can beat that everything everywhere all at once script and I have a 310 page script I'd like to send you right on the money please send it we'll read it we'll read it out loud right yeah we'll do a podcast around it you guys we love you and thank you oh my god that's a pleasure to go by fast yeah so fast
知道的那样，我们确实倾向于和很多相同的演员合作，我们就像一家人，我们喜欢一起闲逛，我们喜欢玩得开心，在片场一起度过很多时间，但我认为我们合作过的次数，可能比我们和任何其他人的合作都要多，所以我想我们已经一起做过六七件事了，是的，只和我合作过一次，而且什么都没播，好吧，我会仔细检查我的邮件，是的，我可以击败那个，《瞬息全宇宙》的剧本，我有一份310页的剧本想发给你，正合我意，请发给我，我们会读的，我们会大声朗读出来的，是的，我们会围绕它做一个播客，你们，我们爱你们，谢谢你们，哦天哪，时间过得真快，是的，太快了
you guys thank you guys for doing this yeah thank you guys and by the way is it's remarkable what you guys have done with this show it's like I listen to it all the time it's true we're we're blowing ourselves crazy surprising and valuable so thank you for even calling it a show good it's such a haphazard piece of shit but but but let me just say this I am I'm so genuinely happy for you guys it couldn't happen to two better more talented nicer fucking dudes I love you guys I'm a huge huge fan of you guys thank you thank you give this business a good name you Russo brothers to you guys all right we love you love you guys have a great rest of the day and we'll see you soon see you guys take care everybody
你们，谢谢你们做这个，是的，谢谢你们，顺便说一句，你们用这个节目所做的事情真的很了不起，就像我一直在听一样，真的，我们为自己感到疯狂的高兴、惊讶和有价值，所以谢谢你们甚至称它为一个节目，这真是个乱七八糟的狗屎，但是，但是，但是，请允许我这么说，我真的为你们感到高兴，这不可能发生在两个更好、更有才华、更好、他妈的更好的人身上，我爱你们，我是你们的超级超级粉丝，谢谢你们，谢谢你们，给这个行业带来了一个好名声，你们罗素兄弟，好吧，我们爱你们，爱你们，祝你们今天剩下的一段时间过得愉快，我们很快再见，再见，大家保重
bye boys bye guys ciao thank you so how about those guys I didn't know they I didn't know they worked that much on arrested development oh yeah the whole first year second most most of the first two seasons I didn't know that yeah I mean there are other people but yeah yeah that's so cool they're so cool they're so like yeah like imagine that Sean like for for all of the the game that arrested development afforded me and will and everyone else says to the show to watch what happened with their career yeah yeah after arrested can you imagine what will and I and everyone else is like oh my god yeah there they go and they've like up until what last year or something they're responsible for the highest grossing film
拜拜，男孩们，拜拜，再见，谢谢，那么，那些家伙怎么样？我不知道他们，我不知道他们在《发展受阻》里做了那么多工作，哦，是的，整个第一年，第二季的大部分时间，大部分的前两季，我不知道那个，是的，我的意思是还有其他人，但，是的，是的，太酷了，他们太酷了，他们太像了，想象一下，肖恩，为了《发展受阻》赋予我和威尔以及其他所有人的所有资本，去看他们职业生涯发生了什么，是的，是的，在《发展受阻》之后，你能想象我和威尔以及其他所有人都在想，哦，天哪，是的，他们去了，他们就像，直到去年还是什么的，他们负责历史上票房最高的电影
in the history of movies history yeah I think probably like number one and number two and now I think what that's number two and number three or whatever the hell yeah avatar they're just responsible for so much health of this business I know and they're legit and they're legitimately great dudes they are such nice guys there is such regular guys from who really have not changed I imagine since they day since the day they moved from Cleveland yeah and in this short amount of time we spent with them I can tell that they're they are very balanced individuals very which is rare this in this business they're very just kind of you know together yeah and a pleasure to be on set with man oh my god and Joe would be
在电影史上，历史，是的，我想可能是第一名和第二名，现在我想那是第二名和第三名什么的，是的，《阿凡达》，他们只对这个行业的这么多健康发展负责，我知道，而且他们是合法的，他们是真正的好人，他们是如此好的人，他们是如此普通的人，自从他们从克利夫兰搬过来的那一天起，我想他们真的没有改变，在我们和他们相处的这段短时间内，我可以看出他们是非常平衡的人，这在这个行业中是很少见的，他们只是那种，你知道，团结在一起的人，是的，在片场和他们在一起真是一种荣幸，哦，天哪，乔会是
when we were doing memory we brought up all up all night when he was coming he was doing up all night and you go like he'd be like having a little something to eat and he was working on his fantasy football which Jason and I used to do with him at various times and then he'd be like you come back in and they go cut and I'd walk in he's like talking to the thing he's looking at his thing and go Joe what do you think goes kind of looks up he's like yeah yeah let's just do it again and maybe just do a little faster at the top there and then look at her in the eye and blah blah blah alright let's go and then he's gonna go back yeah I think maybe I can get a trade for this guy and effortless and just
当我们做《上岸》时，我们一直在讨论他什么时候来，他正在做《上岸》，你会觉得他会吃点小东西，然后他正在处理他的梦幻足球，杰森和我以前在不同时期和他一起做过，然后他会说，你回来然后他们说“卡”，我走进去，他就像在和那东西说话，他看着他的东西，然后说“乔，你觉得怎么样”，他有点抬头看着说“对，对，就再做一次，也许在顶部稍微快一点，然后看着她的眼睛，巴拉巴拉巴拉，好吧，我们走吧”，然后他又要回去了，是的，我想也许我可以为这家伙做个交易，毫不费力，就像
like no just you know what I mean yeah on top yeah rare and their brothers to I mean our brothers supposed to fight all the time I know that's why I wanted to ask them but I didn't want to be weird about it I was like I've never seen them I've honestly never seen them fight no or even get sort of annoyed with one another no not like us three no you know you fucking um what about I didn't ask him how about splitting the money that's got to be a pain I've always wondered about these directing duos do they get twice the directing budget or do they have to split no it's probably one and they split it but I wonder if that still is the case with them you know they make it like a one plus yeah they're big shots
就像，你知道我的意思吗，是的，最棒的是，罕见，他们也是兄弟，我的意思是兄弟不是应该一直吵架吗，我知道这就是为什么我想问他们，但我不想表现得很奇怪，我想我从来没见过他们，老实说我从来没见过他们吵架，没有，甚至没有互相感到厌烦，没有，不像我们三个，没有，你知道你他妈的，怎么说呢，我没有问他，平分钱怎么样，那一定很痛苦，我一直对这些导演二人组感到好奇，他们能得到两倍的导演预算吗，还是他们必须平分，没有，可能是一份然后平分，但我不知道他们是否还是这样，你知道的，他们做得像是一份加号，是的，他们是大人物
you get a one plus but they're they're they're family so it's probably doesn't hurt to split Jason price of bread right now go oh dollar a slice am I close you're laughing at me like I'm not close I've broken bread it's thirty five dollars and maybe fifty cents for the heels or they selling them all together do you get a break if you buy a bunch of slices together and well only if you buy them together well done Sean smart smart smart smart smart this is 100% organic and artisan Lee handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry rub armjab and Bennett barbecue smart loss our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts or you can listen to it right now early on Amazon music or early and add free by subscribing
你得到一份加号，但他们是家人，所以平分可能不会有什么损失，杰森，现在面包的价格是多少，哦，一美元一片，我猜对了吗，你在笑我，好像我猜得不对一样，我切过面包，是三十五美元，鞋跟可能是五十美分，他们是一起卖的吗，如果你一起买很多片，能打折吗，嗯，只有当你一起买的时候，干得好，肖恩，聪明，聪明，聪明，聪明，这是100%有机且由迈克尔·格兰特·泰瑞、鲁布·阿尔姆贾布和贝内特·巴becue手工制作的智能亏损，我们的下一集将在四周内发布，无论你在哪里听播客，或者你现在就可以在亚马逊音乐上提前收听，或者通过订阅来提前收听且无广告
to Wondery plus in Apple podcasts or the Wondery app. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
听Wondery plus的苹果播客或Wondery应用程序。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。